Oh my god.
Holy fucking shit.
Okay.
Okay, I've been like refreshing the auction page and like...
Guys, why is a piece of paper at $1,500?
It's literally a piece of paper.
Okay, I'm gonna like sign like my signature all over it.
But like it's just a piece of paper.
I like how... Okay, I'm gonna... because like it's like you didn't put your name on a nominate because I wanted it.
I'm like, okay.
I'm gonna say I love... I love like the person who wrote... like the person who's bidding on it.
Is like his name is That Troll Boy is an irresponsible spender.
That's me.
What a fucking legend.
Holy fuck.
Okay, I'm gonna put your name up here right now.
That's also a benefit for... the benefit for being the... the major bidder on this fucking paper.
Your name... your name goes up on the screen right now.
Uh...
This guy....
This guy is like fucking...
That's him!
That's him.
This guy is the one that's like currently um... hard bidding on the piece of paper.
He got outbid, by $25!
It's him.
Holy shit.
Well... Well, you're already got outbid...
So I'm gonna time the...
Y- You're sorry bro.
You're already got out bid so you're not on the l- You're not on the screen anymore.
Um, but welcome everybody!
I'm sorry, like I had to talk about the auction for the paper.
Because that shit like blew my mind.
Just seeing $1500 for a piece of paper.
Like there's so many other cool things in the auction.
But the piece of paper already got to $1500.
Oh my god!
I literally, the market value for the thing is like $1.
It's a one.
I like how, oh I got the sniper.
There's a sniper in there too.
Now is my moment to shine.
Oh my god, he's in a bidding war right now with that troll boy.
Alright, for those who wanna like, like live watch, watch it live.
Here's the, here's the bidding war.
The piece of paper.
For those who wanna live watch the paper being bidded.
It's a $2k!
Holy fuck!
$2k!
Anyway.
Welcome everybody.
To, um, hashtag Doki Charity 2024!
Welcome everyone!
This is actually, uh, really crazy.
Um, I've always wanted to do a charity stream.
Um, for the longest time.
Obviously, like, it has a lot of logistics to go around.
Um, I wanna give, uh, before I start talking more about the, uh, serious time.
It's a little bit of serious hour.
But, uh, before I wanna talk about the charity thing.
Uh, I wanna give a giant shout out to Little Men.
Um, they've worked incredibly hard, um, helping me with all of this.
Um, um, it's really, it's actually crazy having, um, um, such a wonderful assistant.
Um, helping me.
They've like, they actually contacted the foundation.
Because at first, Tiltify, um, the auction thing was actually a closed beta option.
And I didn't find out about it until Tuesday.
I didn't realize it was, because I thought that it was open to everybody.
So on Tuesday, I was getting ready to set up the auction.
And I looked at it, and I was like, wait a minute.
It's closed beta.
And I was like freaking out.
I was like, oh my god, guys.
I was like, guys, it's closed beta.
Can you guys like contact Tiltify?
And like, tell them to grant me special permission.
Because I really wanted to access the auction.
And, um, so little men, um, they helped.
They were in contact with Tiltify staff.
And actually gave me the beta, like the option.
Because like, the auction is like reserved for like really big streamers and stuff like that.
So like, obviously like, um, uh, cutie Cinderella for Twitch, uh, did like an auction stream.
As well as a lot of big streamers use the auction feature on Tiltify.
I didn't realize that it was reserved for like big streamers.
Like really big streamers and events.
So I was just like, fuck.
I was just like, oh shit, okay.
That, okay, I fucked up there.
I didn't realize that was a thing.
And so, um, so, um, like I said, a huge shout out to, uh, little men for helping me get in touch with Tiltify.
Like Tiltify people to give me the power to be able to host an auction.
But not only, holy shit!
16,000!
Oh my god!
Okay, to be fair, okay.
At first, I didn't want to include the auction.
Like, the auction fits into like the stretch goals.
But I decided that's not really fucking fair.
And it's all for charity.
So like, I'm like, you know what, Doki?
Be nice.
Give the dragoons.
Give the dragoons a bone.
It's all for charity.
I was like, okay.
I will add the auction to the stretch goals as well.
Um, anyway, anyway, as I was saying, as I was, as I was saying, um, because of that, then I realized the Brain and Behavior Research Foundation was not on the list for auctions.
And I was like, fuck.
Because like, when we got access to the auction, I was like, okay, little man was like, all right, you can do it.
You can, you can host auctions now.
And I was like, yay!
And I was like, trying to do it.
And I was like, wait, where's Brain and Behavior Research Foundation?
They're on Tiltify.
Why aren't they on the auction?
And then, so then, little man had to like, um, get in touch with the Brain and Behavior Research Foundation organization.
And, you know, uh...
Um...
They actually had like a contact, uh, within the organization.
And they managed to, the organization, the foundation managed to connect, uh, their account to Tiltify to receive, uh, auction donations and everything.
And that was, we were able to do that yesterday morning.
Um, they actually, uh, we have had everything set up at like five in the morning on Friday.
Five in the morning on Friday.
And then on Friday, we, um...
Uh, they worked on, uh, putting everything, all the items and everything, um, onto the auction list.
And, um, they were the ones, little man was the ones that were in contact with all the creators.
And all the, uh, all the creators and like, uh, all the artists and all the wonderful creative people around the world in coordinating all the items that are gonna be made.
Uh, for, that was gonna be made for this auction.
So, like I said, a huge shout out to little man for doing all of this.
It's really amazing.
I didn't have to, I didn't have to do all of this myself.
I had incredible help from little man.
Especially with contacting all the official people.
Helping me write all the business emails.
So I don't have to write the business...
I think that's like the best part.
I don't have to write the business emails anymore.
Like, I think that's the part that makes me the happiest.
Cause like, you know, writing emails fucking suck.
I hate, I fucking, I hate, I hate writing business emails.
And I hate writing like professional emails.
So like, huge shout out to little man for helping me write the professional emails.
Especially contacting like Tiltify and, um, contacting Tiltify and, um...
And Brain and Behaviorist.
And the Behavior Research Foundation.
Also, um, I wanna say thank you to everybody that applied for, to be part of the auction.
It was incredibly difficult picking, um, the creators.
Cause I didn't wanna have like too many, like, you know, like, phew.
Like, overwhelm everybody with a lot of items and everything.
Um, so, um, it was very difficult for me to, uh, pick like the items that I want for the auction themselves.
Um, so, um, we actually got more than 200 applicants to be part of the auction.
Um, it was very, very difficult, uh, deciding, like, narrowing down 200 people.
Um, um, little man actually helped out in helping me narrow down the first round.
And in the second round, I had a hundred and, like, I think it was like 300 applicants, I believe.
It was around, like, 300 plus applicants.
And little man narrowed it down to 180 for me.
And then from that 180, I had to pick around 30 people.
Um, I don't actually know the exact number I picked, but like...
From 180, I had to narrow it down even further, um, to what we have now.
Um, like I said, it was incredibly difficult picking, like, uh...
The people to, uh, to be part of this auction.
Um, and I want to say thank you again to all everybody who are donating, um, the items.
Um, I told everybody that I was willing to, uh, chip in and fund because I didn't...
I was... this was like a paid opportunity.
Um, but like also like a huge, uh, thank you to those who, uh, wish to donate those profits to, uh, to charity as well.
Holy shit!
Did someone donate $5,000?
$5,000?
Okay, guys.
I need a...
Who the fuck did...
Guys, give me a second.
Let me open my Tiltify real quick.
Holy fuck!
Okay.
Guys, I've only been streaming for like 20 minutes, guys.
I've only been streaming for 20 minutes.
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
Scott!
Thank you for the $5,000!
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
Thank you for the $5,000!
Um, and yeah, anyway...
Fuck, I lost my train of thought.
What was I saying?
What was I...
I already lost my...
My train of thought right now.
Holy shit!
Okay.
Um...
Anyway...
Like I was saying, it was incre...
It's just...
Um...
Crazy.
It's crazy because like I'm so happy to be able to do something like this.
To be able to do an auction for you guys.
Because like it allows me to work with so many talented people.
All the items in the auction is one of a kind.
Two of a kind.
Mostly one of a kind.
Because I might have...
I might have one too.
But like...
This is a sweater.
Exclusive!
One of a kind!
Okay!
Look, I will also own it one too.
Okay?
But that doesn't count.
Um, I will also own...
Yes!
I will have the piece of paper!
It's literally paper that I own!
Okay!
Okay, but it will be one of a kind for the dragoons plus me, okay?
I will also own one as well.
So then we're matching!
Look, I've had this argument already with my members, okay guys?
It means we will be matching and that raises the value, okay guys?
Us having matching items raises the value of the item itself because we will be matching.
It is live edition paper!
It's my paper!
Who else would have touched the paper other than me?
Just think about it!
It literally has...
My fingerprints!
Okay, wait, actually I'm gonna touch it with gloves.
No, that's actually pretty bad if it has my fingerprints on it.
I would be touching the paper with a glove.
So it would sadly not have my fingerprints on it.
It would not have my fingerprints on the paper.
Because I realize that's a bit scary to get my fingerprints on.
But wait...
Also, I am providing the money for shipping for all of these items.
So do not worry if you're... wherever you live, you're like, oh my god, would they be able to ship it there?
I will be providing the money for the shipping to the creators who will be shipping these products to you if you win the auction.
And also, even if some of the items are not made by me, is not coming from me, I will be sending an exclusive postcard to each winner of the auction.
So each winner of the auction will be able to receive an exclusive postcard made just for this event.
How are we already...
It's crazy.
It's actually...
Guys, the insane...
The insane amount of support from everybody.
Like, we were just starting.
I'm just explaining the event right now.
And like, I'm like, refreshing the like, auction page.
And seeing... everything's been bid.
It's insane.
Everything has been like, already bid on.
And...
And like...
Oh my God, there's so much money.
Like I said, all the money goes directly towards...
It goes directly towards the foundation.
It doesn't go to me.
It goes directly straight to the foundation.
Like, everything's already connected to like, their accounts.
So, they 100% receive the money.
I don't receive anything for those who are like, oh my god, don't care you're gonna receive any.
No, I will not be receiving any of the money.
It goes directly to them via Tiltify.
For those who want to know what is the Brain and Behavior Research Foundation.
They are a charity that looks at providing funding into research for cures and better treatment for mental illness.
So this is like a global thing.
It's not like within one particular country.
It looks into treatments and cures for global research for mental illness and mental disorders.
So they provide majority of funding.
Because I know there's a lot of charities that are going into like salaries and programs and stuff like that.
And like all about the offices and stuff.
But the reason why I chose the Brain and Behavior Research Foundation is that majority of the funding.
Like majority of the money that is raised for this charity organization, for this foundation.
Goes directly to the brain and behavior research foundation.
And funding the research and stuff.
And because I chose it because of also the global appeal.
Because you know finding cures and finding treatments is not like...
It's not like you know centered around one country.
If they find a cure or a better way to treat something for mental illness.
Like people around the world will be able to go for the medicine for it as well.
So it's not like oh you have to go to the doctor.
Or you have to go to this country to be able to receive it.
It is a cure.
It is a better treatment for people around the world.
And that is why I chose this as...
That's why I chose the Brain and Behavior Research Foundation for this particular event.
For the charity and also because people around the world can also donate to this as well.
And because I've set up the YouTube thing.
The YouTube fundraising thing.
Which is more about raising awareness.
Raising programs for it.
A better support system for people with mental illness.
With mental disorders.
On the YouTube one.
Because it was something I could do like quick and instantly.
And something I wanted to do on YouTube.
Because you know a lot of people's eyes were on me.
And it was like the thing I could do right away to help out.
And the Mental Health America helps with that.
So Mental Health America is more so about raising awareness.
And providing support structures and programs.
While the Brain and Behavior Research Foundation is more about trying to find the cure.
And finding better treatment.
And so that's why I felt like you know do two of these at around the same time.
Is the best like way regarding this.
So one if you want to donate to the research.
You can go with the Brain and Behavior Research Foundation.
For the one regarding mental health awareness.
There is the Mental Health America.
That you can donate via the waiting room.
The one the Mental Health America is sadly only has like specific countries.
Can be able to donate via the waiting room.
And that's why I made the Tiltify for like global donations.
So you don't have to worry about like oh well.
Will they be able to accept my donation.
Because I saw there's a lot of issue regarding it.
On the waiting room was that a lot of countries were not able to donate.
To the waiting room.
And that's why I decided to do this particular stream.
And this auction.
To raise money for a second charity as well.
Another 5k?
Guys I was doing a fucking TED Talk.
Holy shit.
Who is it?
TrickyDTayori1000.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Thank you guys.
Holy fuck.
This is insane.
This is actually.
Welcome to my TED Talk.
That'll be 5k per ticket.
Oh my god.
Where we at?
Oh fuck.
Okay.
Shit.
Guys.
I don't know where that hot sauce is.
Oh my god.
6k.
Let's keep laughing to get nothing in stock.
How much did we like.
Okay.
What is like.
How much have we made from the auction alone?
How much did we make from the auction?
Guys.
I need.
Where's my.
Where's my human calculators?
Guys.
How much.
How much did we make on the auction alone?
This is.
Alright.
Where's the piece of.
It's at 4k.
I swear.
What's more.
Damn troll point guys.
I gave up.
Holy shit.
It went to 4k.
And then that troll point was like.
I can't man.
Bro.
It's a piece of paper.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright.
I actually.
I have.
He changed to the keyboard.
Okay.
I actually changed that troll point.
But I won that keyboard.
Because.
Oh shit.
Wait.
What's your full name?
That troll point swapped to the keyboard.
And then the paper was just too expensive man.
Okay.
That's pretty funny.
That's pretty fucking funny.
That you swapped to the.
You swapped to the fucking keyboard now.
Alright.
What's your name?
Where is it?
Where did.
When.
When did you last buy it?
I'm trying to find your full name.
What's your full name?
Pastry.
I like how.
I like how one of the names.
For the cookies.
Is.
We'll learn to bake cookies.
Like they're buying.
The cookie cutter.
And they're like.
I will learn to bake cookies.
For that cookie cutter.
Don't street snipe.
That troll point.
But now I want a keyboard.
Because of this.
Paper is too damn expensive.
Okay.
Let's get him.
That one is good.
That one's actually really good.
I actually like that.
Here you go.
This.
You get to be on the.
You gotta be on the.
On the.
On the stream.
Until somebody snipes you.
And then you're off the screen again.
You're off the screen again.
Jesus Christ.
Also.
For those who are worried.
Like.
Uh.
I'm not going to be able to.
If like.
The winning bid.
Is unable to pay.
For.
The.
Um.
Item.
It will go.
Automatically go towards.
The second winner.
You will have like.
Around.
I think like.
One to two days.
To pay for the item.
Uh.
If you're unable to.
Um.
It will go towards the second.
Winning.
Like the second winner.
So.
Um.
Just to be like.
There is like a backup.
Like a plan B.
Uh.
If that happens.
I'm going to go.
Um.
I'm going to go easy on you.
I think.
Um.
I could.
That you.
Um.
Bid.
When you can't.
Pay.
Um.
Because like.
Nobody would expect that!
You know?
Nobody would expect that to happen!
Yeah, anyway.
And also, emergencies can happen, obviously.
Oh my god, alright.
So, so, okay.
Let me go through each of the items, as well as the creator who go into detail of each of the...
It's like, what are those, like, infomercials?
Alright, welcome to Doki Bird's infomercial time.
Uh, I'm sorry that we do not have an elderly couple who's gonna fall and can't get up.
Or, like, not be able to do something correctly.
And then I'll be like... and then it'll be like black and white.
And then the ex is like, have you ever wanted to do this?
Anyway, welcome to the Doki Bird infomercial for charity.
Uh, I will be introducing each...
Oh, almost to the hot...
Oh my gosh, okay.
Is my... is my parents still here?
Are they... are they...
I don't think they went out for lunch yet.
Okay.
Uh, do they have hot sauce?
That's really spicy.
Oh, yeah.
Okay!
Alright!
My mom's getting the hot sauce now.
She was like, you need to...
You need it now?
I was like, yeah.
She's like, we're there?
Yeah, we're... we're there.
We're fucking there.
What the fuck?
How do we get there?
It's been 30...
They're ready!
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, I'm gonna look through.
Which one is it?
Whoa!
Alright.
This one.
The Last Dab Experience.
Okay.
Let's go.
Yeah.
Alright.
It's called The Last Dab Experience.
Alright, we're gonna...
Over 91% pepper.
Okay.
Um...
It's apparently 2 million.
SHU.
Oh...
I will show it later.
We will do this after I talk about...
After I talk about the charity.
About the auction items.
Guys, there's other stuff I want to talk about...
before we get to the hot sauce.
There's so many things I haven't done on The Stretch Clothes yet!
I was joking!
I haven't even like talked about the stretch.
We haven't gone to any of the actual content of the charity event.
What I've been talking about is just like monitoring what the fuck is going on.
Oh my god.
Wait, I love this.
I love like how they're like fighting so hard right now over the...
over the piece of paper.
Over the piece of keyboard.
Okay, I like this.
So it's between these two people right now.
These two people are fighting it out for the keyboard.
This is not the paper.
This is for the keyboard now.
I honestly will not be surprised if Trollboy is gonna like bounce in between like different auction items.
Just a one.
I'm gonna win something.
I will not be surprised.
Anyway.
As I was saying, does anyone know how far we've raised currently for the auction itself, chat?
I'm actually curious.
How far have we currently raised from just like overall?
52,000?
Oh my god.
What?
We made 52,000 from the auction alone.
By the way, the auction itself will be 24 hours.
So it's going to close tomorrow at... it's gonna close tomorrow at I believe 12 p.m.
PST.
So give time for those around the world to be able to bid because I know it's like super fucking early right now in Asia.
Like it's like 5 or 6 a.m.
over there.
So because of that, we are making sure the auction gives enough time for a bunch of dragoons from around the world to be able to bid on it.
So you know, they don't have to wake up super early and stay up for the rest of the day to like snipe each other.
Anyway, I can finally introduce the items.
Okay.
Alright.
I will finally be able to introduce...
the items of which that is gonna be part of the auction.
Let me find the folder.
I was more prepared earlier, but now I'm like, whoa!
Anyway.
The first item that I'll be talking about...
Okay, I'm gonna refresh.
I'm just gonna go by order from the...
I'm gonna go by order from the site itself.
So.
The first item is...
The...
We have like several amazing...
sculptures and figure makers.
Like I said, this is all like one of a kind.
To the dragoons.
Some might say it's two of a kind because I will also own one.
But let's all just agree that it is one of a kind.
It will never be released.
Re-released.
You will own...
It's one plus one.
You can buy it.
One plus one equals one.
By the way, guys.
So...
Quick maths right there.
Anyway.
Anyway, as I was saying.
Only one in public circulation.
Yes!
I like that.
Only one in public circulation.
So.
As I was saying.
The first item on the list.
Is...
Is a custom Doki sculpture.
By Exeon Figures.
I don't know.
I'm so sorry if like...
I am mispronouncing your name.
Because I'm very bad at that.
So this is the...
This is not the actual figure itself.
This is an example of what they can do.
They have input on the sculpture itself.
In the design.
But this is an example of the type of sculptures and sculpting they can do.
They can give you two options for this.
Obviously, one is the file to print your own sculpture.
Like 3D print your own sculpture.
If you do have a 3D printer and paint it yourself.
Or the creator of the sculpture.
A custom Doki sculpture.
Yes, yes, yes.
It's Bey.
But it's the example they have.
Because by winning this auction.
You can have your input.
And...
On...
On how it would look like.
And...
Basically, the second option is that...
They can make an unpainted...
Resin version.
Of...
They can make an unpainted...
Resin version.
Of the...
Sculpture themselves.
And it will be shipped to you.
So you can like paint it yourself and everything.
But the...
But it's also made of resin.
So it is...
So...
So obviously it is...
Very high quality.
And everything.
Um...
What else am I...
What else do I want to talk about?
Um...
Like I said, each auction...
Will be...
Each auction winner will be sent an exclusive...
An exclusive...
Postcard.
So...
Everything...
Even if it's like something regarding no physical item.
You will also be sent...
Um...
You will also be sent the postcard.
An exclusive signed postcard from me.
Um...
So that is...
Number one.
Is a custom Doki sculpture.
Uh...
Number two.
The second item.
That I'll be showing.
Is...
Wow!
A one of a kind.
Um...
Custom...
Doki bird themed PC.
This...
Is not just a PC case.
It will also be...
A customized...
Fully built...
Doki...
PC.
So it's not just a case by the way.
I know some people were wondering...
If it's like just a PC case or not.
But it will also be a fully customized PC.
That fits around like...
Me.
That would be like around my color scheme and everything.
Um...
So this is by Celeste Fleur.
It was valued at $3,500.
Like including the PC parts and everything.
Um...
And now it's at $6,100.
Wow!
So like the PC parts itself...
Was...
Um...
Was going...
Was...
Uh...
$3,500.
Including the customization.
Um...
This is not from Hyatt.
This is actually from...
Uh...
A...
Um...
A user...
Uh...
Named Celeste Fleur.
Who is using a Hyatt case.
Just so you guys know.
Uh...
I just want to...
I just wanted to clarify.
For those who are confused.
Um...
This is actually just using a Hyatt case.
So...
Um...
It will be...
Uh...
So it's valued at $3,500.
Um...
Including the parts itself.
And like the decorations and everything.
Um...
And...
Yeah.
So it's not just a case.
I know a lot of people are confused.
That it was just going to be the case itself.
But no.
It is a fully...
Cus...
Like fully made custom PC.
Um...
I...
It is just a case.
Item number three.
The cookie cutters.
These are so cute.
I love...
These are actually so fucking cute.
Oh my god!
Alright.
Anyway.
So the cookie cutters.
Item number 3.
From Reesoo.
So there are multiple cookie cutters.
There's...
It's multiple styles.
But each auction item that you bid on will come with two cookie cutters.
One will be my face and the other one will be a dragoon.
So it is basically your pick on whether you want the dragoon to have a knife or you want the dragoon with no knife.
The chunky goons.
So this is item 3 to like insert...
3 to 4, 5, 6, 7.
Item 3 to 7.
The different expressions of cookie cutters.
And I think it's very very fucking cute.
And I love how...
I love how like one of them is like, I will learn how to bake cookies if I win this auction.
I love the fucking...
You guys are so creative.
You're like...
Some of this like, never baked cookies in my life.
And I will drop an entire paycheck for this.
The one guy is like, I never baked cookies in my life.
But I need this.
This is now the next...
This is my life now.
I will learn how to bake all the cookies if I have this cookie cutter.
Oh my god.
There's another guy that's like, I just won something for $500.
I only have $500.
Please.
I just...
I need this exclusive...
Exclusive postcard.
Anything that's under $500.
Please.
Anyway.
That is item 3 to 4, 5, 6.
Sorry.
I'm really bad at counting.
3 to 7.
Alright.
Next item on the list.
The next item on the list.
Boop.
Alright.
The next item on the list is a...
I know this is not me.
I know that is...
I know that is Sakura Miku Hatsune.
I know that, guys.
But this is...
This is an example of their...
Oh my god.
The next item is Hatsune Miku?
Doki.
I did not realize you were Hatsune Miku.
Thank you.
Is that Doki, but pink?
Anyway.
The next item on the list is a custom Doki sign print from this artist.
This artist's name is...
I'm so sorry.
I'm definitely going to butcher your name.
Aircell?
My mod would be linking their Twitter.
Their Twitter and chat.
So this you can see the art style.
I would be printing, don't worry, it's going to be a high-quality print.
Do not worry.
It's not going to be like paper.
I mean, it's paper.
But it would be like, nice paper.
It would be very nice paper.
OK, guys...
It's not going to be...
You know like when you're at anime conventions and then...
You know like okay, so like you know like anime conventions where you're buying like anime prints.
It's gonna be like that, but signed.
Okay?
I love paper.
Like 4.4k nice.
I don't know like I don't know it would be that nice, but it would be nice.
It'll be pretty good.
Really nice colors too.
I'll make sure it'll be very good colors like the best quality type of colors and the best quality type of paper that you can get.
And I will be signing it!
So it will be a Doki sign print from this artist.
Beautiful art style.
Really lovely colors and everything.
So this is an example of their art style.
Like it's on paper?
Fuck yeah!
Oh my god, don't you don't need to say anything more.
It's on paper.
That's all I need to know.
Anyway.
Next item on the list.
Let me see if I can find the picture they've sent us.
Alright.
The next item on the list.
Okay, this is gonna take up like my face real quite fast.
Okay, here we go.
I never thought I could I could I could hang this low.
Alright, the next next item on the list.
It is a hardcover sticker book with three four exclusive stickers to include in your collection.
Look guys, it's multiple paper.
It's multiple paper.
Guys, it's not just one paper.
It's multiple papers in a book.
Okay, that's like come on.
That's like I don't even know.
75 sheets of paper!
Guys.
75 sheets of paper in one.
But it's not signed.
Okay.
You want to see the picture?
Oh, get an exclusive signed postcard!
Okay.
That's almost like it was signed!
Anyway.
Anyway, it's more than one.
Anyway, this next item from Ravenmon.
I was very surprised when Ravenmon wanted to join the charity auction.
Because I actually very heavily admire ReRi's stuff.
Ever since like I saw them at like like like online stores.
Ever since like I saw them at like like online stores.
I'm at Artist Alley.
They won't know who I am.
It's been years.
I actually own multiple items from RiRi.
Like for years.
Because they are like... they've been doing Artist Alley for a really, really long time.
So actually, I've seen them at convention and I've actually...
They will never know!
They'll never know who it was.
So, I'm actually... heavily admire RiRi because I've actually owned several of their...
Like, merch that they've made in Artist Alleys.
And so, yeah.
I'm really, really happy that they're part of the charity auction.
Bro, it wasn't even four years ago!
It might be like eight years ago.
They've been like... they've been doing Artist Alley.
And like selling stuff online for so long.
Like, it wouldn't even be four years.
Maybe like eight.
Maybe like eight years ago.
Like, they are like a veteran to Artist Alley and conventions.
Okay, and then I like... I will not be surprised if RiRi was like, I have not been selling for eight years.
And before they come in and call me, I was like, Doki, I have not been selling for eight years.
That is... that is not true.
Okay.
Well, it felt like eight years.
Okay?
It felt like eight years.
Anyway... anyway...
It is a sticker book with exclusive stickers.
Obviously, I believe the stickers will be based around me.
Unless they're random stickers.
But I think it's healthy to assume it's gonna be about me.
You're right.
I'm a veteran.
A hard and...
I knew it!
I was like, eight years does feel like a really long time though.
So like, maybe it wasn't eight years.
But I knew!
I just know that I was... I bought something from her.
Maybe eight years ago.
Anyway,
as I was saying...
So yeah, this is gonna be a sticker book!
Yay!
With seven years.
And I'm gonna be five sheets of paper.
That's a lot of paper, guys.
It is a lot.
Alright, next item!
Next item on... on the list.
Let's see.
What is...
Where is it?
Where... where is the...
Where is the...
Uh...
Okay, this one is...
Whoa, this one is a big one.
You can see the beautiful R.
Alright!
The next one on the list.
Um...
A custom signed metal poster!
I will be signing these!
I believe, cause it says sign...
Alright.
This is not just regular paper.
Oh my gosh.
This is...
Okay, I'm gonna...
I can't...
It is not just regular paper.
But metal paper.
Well...
Look, there is a tier list.
Metal paper.
Sticker paper.
A4 paper.
So...
That one is...
This is gonna be a signed...
It's gonna be shiny.
Okay?
It is going to be shiny.
Garbage!
What the fuck you talking about?
Hahaha!
But...
It's gonna be...
It's gonna be metal paper.
Um...
And the artist is Paranoia.
www.
Um...
And so...
Obviously, it is a...
Your character here.
So, they will be drawing you and me together.
Uh...
And...
I need to read this whole thing.
Sorry, I didn't read the...
Hahaha!
So, you choose one of the three poses...
That they've given...
Uh...
Given you...
To choose from.
If you win the auction.
And...
Obviously, it says like...
What they can and can't draw.
So, there are like...
Stuff you can't do.
And stuff you can do.
Um...
And then also their...
Beautiful art style!
Their art style is so fucking pretty!
Oh my god!
It's actually gorgeous.
And that is the other...
Next item...
Next item on the list.
What's after that?
Oh!
We're in the plushy territory now!
I think...
I think we might go back to like non-plushy areas too.
Um...
Let's see...
Where is the...
Where did I put the...
Okay, here we go.
Next item on the list!
It's gonna be a plushy!
Also, what I love about like...
All of the...
Creators that are...
That are part of this...
Auction...
Is that...
Everybody...
Chose a different...
A lot of people chose different outfits.
It's not just one outfit, obviously.
I had many, many outfits.
So it's really nice, cause it's like...
Um...
All different outfits...
Uh...
Are represented...
Um...
In the auction.
So if there's like a particular...
Doki fashion that you like...
Uh...
Maybe you'll find it in one of the auctions.
Um...
Anyway!
So this is by Rimi Plushies!
Um...
Rimi Plushies!
It is 36 inches sitting!
That is a really big plushy!
I'm just gonna say...
Like 36 inches for a plushy is pretty tall!
It is very tall!
Um...
Yes, this is by Rimi Plushies!
Your very own exclusive one of a kind in public circulation...
Uh...
Plushy for you to own!
Is that free...
3 feet?
Oh my...
Okay, no...
Is that actually 3 feet?
That's...
Sorry!
I can't count in inches!
Uh...
I use feet!
Oh my god!
That is...
3 feet is a lot actually!
Holy shit!
Alright!
That is one of the plushies that's gonna be in the auction!
Next item!
Alright, the next item is actually very interesting!
This next product...
Um...
I was...
At first when...
Uh...
Lilman...
Because Lilman made me an excel sheet...
Of...
Um...
Of like...
All the people that...
Um...
Applied...
That got through the first round...
Um...
And when I saw this...
I was like...
What the fuck is in...
Like...
I don't even remember what they wrote...
Oh!
IEM!
Yeah, I was like...
What the fuck is an IEM?
That is not paper!
What the fuck?
Look!
It's a paper!
Everybody will have paper in the end!
Because everyone is gonna be sent...
A fucking...
Uh...
Postcard!
Anyway!
So I was like...
What is an...
What's an...
I was so confused!
I was actually incredibly confused!
And then I had to like...
Google...
Google it...
And I was like...
Oh!
It said...
Yeah...
An in-ear monitor...
I was like...
That's how someone was like...
That's a for paper right there...
Anyway!
It will...
Be...
A one of a kind...
In public circulation...
Um...
Doki bird...
IEM!
From Kotari Audio...
Uh...
So it's like...
Fancy earphones...
So...
Uh...
I love to show you guys like...
The designs they sent me...
Um...
Because I had to look at the pictures to actually realize like...
What is that?
I'm sorry!
I'm not good with like...
Technical stuff!
Guys...
I'm sorry!
I'm not good with like...
Technology...
Okay...
To an extent...
I am okay with technology...
But like...
I was so confused...
Because I didn't know...
What the fuck IEM was...
So...
This would be like...
The concept...
That they've like...
Given us...
Um...
So you can see...
It has my Oshimark...
And my colors...
And everything...
Um...
So you can see...
You can have like...
You know...
Um...
Like I said...
One of a kind...
In public circulation...
Um...
Typical V2...
Yes!
I get all my knowledge...
From other people...
So...
This is like...
The concept...
Um...
The concept render...
Of what it would look like...
Um...
And then they also sent...
Like a...
Box...
Of like...
The packaging...
And everything...
So...
There's actually...
It will also come with like...
A...
Sticker...
An exclusive sticker...
Made for it...
As well...
As well as...
Um...
There's like...
A lot of things going on with it...
So...
Uh...
There's also gonna be like...
Exclusive box art...
And stuff...
That...
Package paper...
There's your paper!
There it is!
The paper!
So there's gonna be...
Exclusive packaging...
And everything...
Um...
As well as...
The...
Like the...
The art of...
The artist...
That would be a part of it...
So...
Um...
So like...
Sticker artist...
So yours gonna be your...
Exclusive sticker art...
Stickers...
As well as...
Box art...
So here are the credits...
Of every...
Everybody that is...
Part...
Of the...
Um...
Of the IEM...
Guys...
I swear to god...
How much has the A4 paper gone for now...
I swear...
Oh my god...
4,400...
Okay, they stopped 37 minutes ago.
Okay, that is very reassuring.
That is very reassuring that the war has stopped now.
I feel a lot better.
Okay.
Anyway, next item on the list.
This is very... this is an interesting one.
It's really, really cute.
So, this is a sterling silver dragoon necklace.
It is made from sterling sticker.
It is from Kotaku... Kotaku... Taku?
And it is a full on necklace pendant.
I believe it is also included.
It includes a chain for it as well.
So, it's... you gotta have your chonky goon with you.
On your neck at all times.
Yeah, sterling silver too.
Their work is absolutely beautiful.
I remember looking at their portfolio for everything.
And, oh my god, they have like Mario stuff too.
Like, I'll show you guys.
I'll give like a shout out to their Etsy.
Like, look at their... the stuff they have made.
It's actually crazy.
Like the Mario star pendant.
And it's actually really well done.
Like the stuff they've made on their Etsy store.
So, huge shout out to their work.
It was beautiful to see their portfolio.
But yes!
The sterling silver chonky goon is this item.
Alright, the next one is...
Although I do have a Doki Makura in my official shop.
You can have a chance to own an exclusive one of a kind in public circulation Doki Makura.
Uh...
I buy... I buy King Biscuit.
Which I would admit is sexier than anything I've ever seen.
Whew!
This has to be...
So fucking high.
Like, it was like, we're about to get banned, Doki!
NO!
Don't show this to the public!
So...
Uh...
This is by Keen Biscuit.
Like I said, one of a kind.
Doki Makura.
It's just so fucking hot that only one can be made and owned at all times.
So I hope whoever wins this is a very lucky individual in accurate talking.
Alright.
Alright, anyway.
Anyway.
Okay.
So anyway.
That is this item in the auction.
It's life-size.
Yes, it is.
It is life-size.
It is very accurate to how I actually am proportion-wise.
It's all waste.
Also the butt too.
Also the butt.
Alright, anyway.
Anyway.
Yes, it's automatically accurate.
The anatomy is very accurate.
Alright, anyway.
Anyway.
That is this item in the auction.
Alright, next up.
Next up.
This is not a physical item.
So there is no picture.
There is no picture.
This is not a physical item.
This is basically I will collab with an indie or streamer of your choice.
So I'm just going to read out the description.
But basically, if you win this auction, you can pick an indie Vtuber or like a streamer of your choice.
Who is your favorite streamer.
And you want to give them like a big break.
You want to have more eyes on them.
And I will try to reach out to them for a collab.
Obviously, it is up to their choice if they wish to collab with me.
And if they do decline, obviously you will have to give me a plan B on who to reach out after.
Big in the streaming community and have a chance to have a lot of eyes on them.
And be able to maybe have this like a big break for them as well.
So that is one of the... this is the one the non-physical items.
Non-physical items that I'm giving.
But yeah, anyway.
Next item on the list is also a non-physical item.
Pick a game for me to stream.
So if there is a game that you've always wanted me to stream.
But I chose to ignore you.
I will not be able to ignore you anymore.
By winning this auction.
Except for Visage.
Because that is a stretch goal.
So by winning this auction for pick a game for me to stream.
You can force me to stream your favorite game to completion on stream.
So it will not be to 100%.
It will be to like the end of the story.
And that is within TOS obviously.
Like so I can stream it.
And like...
There is no MMOs.
MMOs are not allowed.
Just so you guys are wondering.
MMOs are not allowed by winning this.
Because there is no way to fucking complete MMOs.
But I will stream it to completion.
Obviously if you try to be like super cheeky.
And be like oh my god.
What about Destiny 2?
Because there is no end to Destiny 2.
Because they will keep ruining it.
And releasing missions and like stories and DLCs.
That is not allowed.
I can like...
You can't be cheeky on this.
You can't.
I am giving you a chance to be like play an RPG game.
Like a JRPG game.
Because I choose not to play JRPG games.
Because I know.
I know that like for me.
JRPGs and me just do not mix very well.
I haven't found one that I actually enjoyed.
So...
This is your chance.
To force me.
If you win the bid.
To force me to stream a JRPG.
Especially when JRPGs are like fucking 100 plus hour fucking streams.
Even if you are speed running to the end.
Um...
But yeah if you win the auction obviously.
Um...anyway.
Next item on the list.
Ha ha ha.
It is.
The piece of paper.
Ha ha ha.
This is.
The next item on the list.
It is your fucking.
A4 paper.
Where I will sign.
I will cover it up.
How did that go up?
Three minutes ago?
You haven't been bidding for like one hour that you came back?
This person hasn't bid for an hour?
And then they're like, this is it, this is my time to shine now.
I'm waiting for...
Anyway, they just like showed up.
They literally stopped bidding when it was at $3,000.
They stopped at $3,000 and they had to go to the bank.
Sorry, they had to make like a quick deposit real quick, you know.
They had to do some quick like...
They had to take a quick loan real quick to be able to keep going.
Anyway.
So, this piece...
Yes, it's not just a piece of paper.
I literally wrote that it's going to be a piece of paper covered with my signature.
So I'll be like writing my signature on it.
Anyway, anyway.
So it's not just pure white paper.
I will have...
I would taint it with my signature.
That's why the paper is now 10K.
I'm going to be like, So, anyway.
That is that item on the list.
Next item on the list is...
A private one-to-one gaming session with me of any game of your choice.
So it will go maximum three hours maximum.
Because like, I don't know if you suddenly pick like a two-hour game.
Like what the...
So...
We will be setting...
If you win this...
If obviously if you win this...
Okay, it's going to be multiplayer.
You can't be like, Oh my gosh.
I want a private one-to-one gaming session with Doki.
I'm going to make her play this.
That doesn't...
That's not how it works.
It's just a multiplayer game.
It's going to be a...
A multiplayer game guys.
But it is going to be a private session.
Three hours maximum.
And why wouldn't you spend with Mr. Man or other little man and I will be like coordinating schedule to figure out like it'll be on one of my rest days.
Obviously, it'll be on one of my rest days and we will play together.
The private session.
It won't be streamed or anything.
It'll be like a one-to-one session for charity.
Yeah, that is that chair that item.
How many more do we have?
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven, twelve, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19.
Oh my gosh, we have 24.
Sorry.
This has to be the longest ad session ever.
That's great because then I don't have to...
I don't have to fucking worry about eating the hot sauce yet.
I have 20 more items before I get to eat the hot sauce.
Hey.
Anyway.
The 24-hour unskippable.
That's how I like my ads.
Unskippable.
No plugin can save you.
Weird fucking...
No ad blocker or plugin can save you now.
All right.
Next item on the list.
Let me grab the picture for this one.
Where did I put it?
Okay.
Auction photos.
Also, shout out to Lil Man for compiling all the photos for me.
Into like one folder.
Thank you.
I love it.
Next item on the list is a drag...
I'm going to mispronounce like what it's called.
A dragoon amigurumi.
So by HeyitsJ.
So you get to have a chance to win two dragoon crochet plushies.
One wears a shirt.
They're not naked.
They have a shirt on.
So this is your chance to win both of them.
It's not just one, but two of them as well.
So this is incredibly cute.
I love crochet.
Crochet is so fucking hard.
I was like watching a video on like...
What's it called?
Wubbles?
Apparently this like viral TikTok like crochet kit or something called the Wubbles or something.
It's like the Wiggles, but like I guess less Australian.
I don't know.
Wait, are they from New Zealand?
I can't.
I'm sorry, Australians, New Zealanders.
I get you guys confused.
Which one is which?
Like what?
I mean, I don't get the country confused.
I get like who's from where?
Like, like, because like the accents are a little bit similar.
So like I don't remember if like if there's like a famous actor.
I'd be like, are you New Zealand or Australian?
I sometimes forget.
Oh, anyway.
But anyway.
I was like watching a video on like Wubble kit or whatever, like, like some arts and crafts YouTuber that that was like introducing the Wubbles and it's some like viral crochet kit.
And they were like, I have never done crochet before.
So we're going to see if it is beginner friendly.
And I was like, what the fuck?
I was just like watching like this is beginner friendly?
I was just like, holy fuck.
Like, oh my God.
I cannot do arts and crafts.
Arts and crafts is like, I can't.
I don't have like, first off, I don't think I have the patience.
The last time I had the patience for arts and crafts stuff is when I think this is like, I don't know.
This is like a, this is like an Asian thing.
Like when you're a kid.
But there's these like arts and crafts where you can fold the paper into these like triangle pieces.
But you draw.
That's art.
Drawing is just art.
There's just art.
There's no crafting in it.
There's no, there's no crafting.
It's just art.
Anyway.
Anyway, it's not, I mean, it's not really origami.
I'm not talking about origami, but like it's like using origami to make something.
But like, it's basically you make these little triangle things and then you piece these triangle things together into a structure.
Um, and I used to do that.
Um, as a kid.
Like I would fold a lot of these.
Like triangles.
And then it would be like, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
And then there's Doraemon.
I have one.
Cause they, they always sell them at Daiso.
They, I remember as a kid.
They always had these kits at Daiso.
And then I would buy like the hamster.
I have the hamster one.
And then I had like Doraemon.
And then I did that.
Um, I did that as a kid.
Is that what it's called?
The Tangram?
But yeah, that was like the extent of my crafting.
I also did like plushie making.
Um, for school.
Um, but like, um, it was, it was a bit of a mess.
It was a bit of a mess.
Anyway.
Holy shit!
We're $48,000?
Oh my, don't worry.
I have a list of stretch goals just in case this happened.
I was, I was like a little bit, I was like, okay.
Thinking of stretch goals is like one of the hardest, honestly, one of the hardest things ever.
Because I'm like, what the fuck do people want?
Like, I was just like, what the fuck do people want?
What do you want?
So I had like an huge list of things.
Anyway, after I introduce all the auction items, I'll talk about the stretch goals.
Which we've practically mostly hit already.
Like, we're already mostly there on the ones that are officially on the stretch goals.
Anyway.
Um, the next item, it is not a physical item.
It is pick the next official Doki outfit.
So what that means is that you get to, you get to help pick, decide the theme and help design.
Like, and give your input.
Uh, give your input on, on, um, on what my next official outfit is going to be.
The one after, you know, and the one after the, the, not this, not after this, but like after the other one.
So, um, so obviously it has to be within TOS YouTube Twitch friendly for streaming.
So I can actually wear it.
I can actually wear it on stream.
So, so by winning this auction, you can be part of the process and part of like deciding, like, you know, we'll be sending you like artwork, concept art, and you have to decide, like pick between the concept art and give input on what you want included.
And the concept art, obviously you're not going to be paying for the, the fucking outfit.
I will be paying for the outfit.
So you don't have to worry about like paying for charity.
And also the outfit itself, like the illustration for the outfit.
Do not worry.
I'll be paying for the skin suit being made like with the, the rigging and everything.
I will be paying for the laundry of the skin suit and the, and the crafting of the skin suit.
So you don't have to worry about that.
Um, you get to be part of the process.
Uh, so you, so that is okay.
That's, so that's all that you have.
You don't have to pay after the auction.
Um, next item on the list is a...
Okay, let me put it up on the screen.
Let me see if I can find the right, the right picture.
So the next item, um, it's not this piece of paper.
It's a concept art.
The next item is a dragoon wood carving.
This is the concept art of the wood carving.
It's self.
Um, so they have, they've actually sent in, um, multiple like, uh, stuff they've done in the past.
So here is like something they've, oh my God, this fucking picture is giant, enormous.
Um, so this is like a proof of, uh, something they've actually done before.
And it's, it's made of trees.
So it's almost like paper.
It's the same material.
It's the same fucking material.
.
So this is like one of the things they've done in the past.
So it's a full, uh, wood carving that they've carved themselves.
But, um, instead of that, you would get a dragoon.
You will get dragoon.
And you can choose between different dragoon types.
Like, you know, someone, you can add an egg at the bottom too.
Like, you can add an egg in the bottom.
Like I said, concept art is subjected to change.
And, um, it is by, uh, Chen.
I'm sorry.
Chen09 is the artist.
I have to like look at it for a second and be like, how do I pronounce it?
Chen?
Because there's a one.
So, so, um, so this is the next item.
Okay.
Next letter item on the list.
We're almost there.
We're like, okay, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven, twelve, thirteen, fourteen, fifteen, sixteen, we're seventeen.
We might, sorry, I keep getting distracted.
And I keep zazadonning.
I'm supposed to, we have not got to any part of the auction.
Like, we're still stuck in the auction part of it.
I apologize.
We're still, we're still introducing the auction.
We will get there soon.
I hope you're still entertained.
I hope you're still entertained while we're still on the auction.
It's not stalling.
I'm literally introducing the items.
I like how someone's like, stop apologizing.
Explain faster.
Stop apologizing.
Okay.
Anyway.
Next item on the list.
I need to find the...
Okay, here we go.
Another...
Okay, whoa.
This is a giant...
Oh my god, that's a big ass tomato.
Okay.
I need to resize this real fast.
Next item.
It is another signed print.
This is a work in progress.
It is by...
Camu on Twitter.
And like I said, this is a...
This is going to be a signed print sent by me.
Drawn by this illustrator.
Look at all these fucking tomatoes.
Who the fuck are they?
And why are they not eaten yet?
I can't believe it.
Who let these guys out their cage?
Who let them out?
It's not dinner time yet.
All right.
And anyway, this is one of the...
Another signed print.
Another signed print that you can win.
Next up is also another signed print.
If I can find it.
Oh my gosh.
It is landscape style this time.
All right.
This one is by Shows140.
This is going to be another signed print.
Obviously, this is a concept art.
So it will be...
Oh my God.
We're at fucking 50k already?
Oh...
Okay, let me...
All right, guys.
All right.
You know what?
The next stretch goes...
I'm just going to let you guys pick on the list.
Because like...
I can't...
I have a giant list of like...
What to do afterwards.
So you guys can pick on the list afterwards.
After each goal we hit.
Let me...
All right.
Sorry.
A little intermission.
We got to fix this now.
Because we made it past...
Holy fuck.
We already made it past 50k.
Oh my God.
Thank you, everybody.
This is...
Oh my God.
I can't believe we already made it past 50k.
That's...
Oh my God, guys.
Oh my God.
I'm so...
That's actually crazy.
Oh my God.
It's only been an hour.
We raised so much.
I mean, if we count the charity...
We've made like...
If we count the auction...
And the fundraising from like the one on the YouTube waiting room.
This...
It's like...
We've like raised like...
We've raised like 150,000 dollars technically.
If you think about it.
Because we also have the one from the YouTube charity.
And then the auction itself.
So we've already made 150k.
Thousand.
That's a lot of money.
That's...
Oh my God.
That's just insane.
All right.
Let me put like the...
Okay.
Where the fuck...
Incentives.
Okay.
Milestone.
All right.
Add milestone.
Okay.
60,000.
Um...
I don't know.
Um, chat chooses from list.
I'm sorry.
All of this is just going to be chat chooses from list.
Chat chooses from list.
Okay.
Wait.
Not visage.
All right.
You guys want to know when we hit visage?
When you guys get visage?
Okay.
I'll let you know.
You guys get visage...
Okay.
400,000 dollars.
You know what?
Okay, you guys wanna know?
Alright, here.
This is the only way you'll get Visage to completion.
This is the only way you'll ever get Visage.
For those who keep demanding Visage.
Visage to end of story.
$400,000.
That's fucking right.
It's like 60k chat chooses from list, not Visage.
400k to leave Visage.
It's not a scam!
How is this a scam?
You cannot say a charity is a scam.
You cannot say that.
You cannot say charity, that's fucked up.
Hey, don't worry.
I do have other reasonable goals.
I will play Elden Ring for one stream.
See, this is reasonable.
Guys.
That's so fucking reasonable.
I will play Elden Ring for one stream.
300k.
If you want me to finish it.
That's 400k.
That's 500k.
Hey, wait a second.
Okay, I'll play Elden Ring for one stream.
And kill two bosses.
Okay, I'll kill two bosses.
And kill two boss...
Okay.
Defeat...defeat...defeat two boss.
Okay, I couldn't...
I can't like put the full bosses.
I can't...
I'll kill me right BOS.
Because like I ran out of space.
So...
I ran out of space.
So it's just BOS.
Sorry, look.
I'm character limitations.
Character limitations is hard.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm putting this fucking...
The stretch goals right now for us.
Alright.
At 100k, I will play Brood War.
I will play Brood War.
There we go.
Okay.
Bam.
Easy.
Alright.
There we go.
Okay, we'll figure out the other stretch goals later.
We'll figure out the other ones later.
These are like the main goals to strive for.
Like the main ones.
It's not an ad.
I'm actually trying to figure out the stretch goals right now.
Okay.
200k.
At 150k, I will...
Pokemon Smasher Pass.
200k.
There we go.
You can look...
You can judge my fucking taste in Pokemon at 200k.
There we go.
Look, we have 100, 200, 300, 400...
We'll figure out the other stretch goals later, okay?
This has been a long ad.
We have like the general ones yet now.
We have like the general idea of what we want for now.
Alright.
Anyway.
Where was I on this long ad campaign?
Alright.
Okay.
Next up!
Look, we still have fucking 16 more items to go through.
This is so cute.
I actually own a clay puff figure.
A long...
That was made like 3 years ago.
3-4 years ago.
Obviously, you know, the one I own was like 3-4 years ago.
Clay puff figure.
And now she's like even better!
They're like a better...
You know, they have 3-4 years of experience now.
And this is a figure.
Me being E.P.
And this is the...
I think like the base of it.
On the end.
But yeah, it's so fucking cute!
This is by Clay Puff!
Uh...
And honestly, it's made of polymer clay.
And acrylic.
So it's a Doki themed standee!
So it'll just be there.
It'll just be like looking at you.
Me E.P.
and looking at you while sleeping.
Me, me, me, me, me, me.
Um...
It's actually already finished.
So these are one of the items that will be sent out...
Not instantly, but around March 15th.
Um...
So these are items that are already finished.
And you can receive it...
Uh...
Right away!
Well, not right away, but like...
You know.
Like fast enough, you know.
Um...
But yes, that is the sculpture from Clay Puff.
Alright, next up!
Ooh, this one!
This one is...
This one will be...
I think you guys would really like.
This is a...
The next one is...
Another sculpture.
Let me see if I can...
If I can pull it up.
So, I will give you guys...
What they've done in the past.
So...
They have sculpted this...
In the past.
This is going...
This is from Juicy Buns.
And this is like...
This is a...
One of the works they've done in the past.
And basically...
That's not me.
But they will make a version that's me.
Just so you guys know.
I know that's not me.
This is a sample.
But the actual sculpture will look like this.
Just so you guys know.
The actual sculpture.
That's not you!
This is what the actual sculpture...
It's gonna be.
It is gonna be a...
High quality resin.
And it will be sent...
To Japan.
To be professionally painted.
And it's sent to you.
So it's a...
One of a kind.
In public circulation.
Disclaimer.
A one of a kind.
Basically...
Resin figure.
That is professionally painted.
By a painter in Japan.
And...
It will be sent out...
By end of May.
So...
Holy shit!
Okay, anyway.
Anyway.
I didn't even realize how many bids it has now.
Oh my fucking god.
Okay.
Anyway.
It is at 6,300.
At the moment.
But I think it's actually really fucking cool.
That it's actually gonna be sent to...
To someone.
It's not like an unpainted resin figure.
It's gonna be sent to...
Somebody in Japan.
To fully paint it out and everything.
So it's like a professional figure in general.
Like it's actually a figure.
That's like the really cool thing about this.
Alright.
Next up.
Let me...
Pull out the next work.
Oh hey.
I got my chicken.
It's been an hour and thirty minutes.
Thank god I have it.
Who just gave me my chicken.
Laughing cause I'm scared.
I'm laughing cause I'm scared right now.
Laughing cause I'm scared right now.
Anyway.
I will show you guys.
Stuff they've done in the past.
So.
Ummm.
Well.
This is not me.
Laughing.
Just so you guys know.
This is not me.
This is an example of what they've done in the past.
So.
Basically.
It is a cut out art.
In an acrylic block.
So it will look like.
Ummm.
It will look like this.
So it will be like in a professional block.
Ummm.
Of the artwork.
And umm.
I'm getting to it guys.
I am getting to it.
Laughing.
This is by JQHN.
Harold.
I'm sorry.
I pronounced the name.
It's JQHN.
Which I assume.
It's John.
I assume it's John.
But it's with a Q.
Ummm.
So.
This is the concept art that they gave us.
Ummm.
Where is it?
So this is what the concept art would look like.
Ummm.
It's not this.
This is a concept.
Just so you guys know.
This is not what's being sent to you.
This is a concept art.
This is not the $900 thing you're bidding on.
Laughing.
This is a concept art.
What it would look like.
So.
And it will be in this acrylic block.
Ummm.
And this is from John.
On Twitter.
Well not just John.
It's like John Harold.
But like I'll just call him John.
Laughing.
Alright.
Next item.
It's another plushie.
Another plushie.
Boop.
Yeah.
I really do like how all of them are like different outfits.
It's so cute.
It's like which dokey bird do you want to have in your collection?
Which one?
This item.
Dokey plushie number two.
So.
Ummm.
This one is by Plush Mayhem.
And umm.
Oh their.
Their previous works are incredibly adorable.
Let me show you guys what they sent to us.
Uhhhh.
If I have it.
Woo.
Wait do I have one?
Oh wait I don't.
Laughing.
Oh wait I do.
I do.
Okay I do.
I actually do.
Here you go.
This is some of the stuff they've done in the past.
Like their style.
And everything.
So this is basically like I said.
Like handmade plushie.
Ummm.
And uhh.
It is uhh.
It is by Plush Mayhem.
So this is what they've done in the past.
But instead of that bitch.
I'm sorry she's not a bitch.
I don't even know who she is.
Laughing.
It's a term of endearment.
It will look like this.
Laughing.
It will.
Look it's a term of endearment.
If I call you a bitch.
It's like a nice thing.
Okay.
Like wait don't call your friends.
Bitch.
Laughing.
Like sup bitch.
Okay anyway.
Next up on the list.
Um.
I am nice.
What do you mean?
You can't say that when I'm literally doing a charity stream.
Laughing.
I am exempt from that.
For the day.
For today.
I am nice.
Laughing.
This is like my nice day.
This is actually my nice day.
Um.
Anyway.
Laughing.
Toxic positivity.
Okay.
I am nice.
She yells out and screams to chat.
Laughing.
Anyway.
Next item.
The next item on the list.
This one I am actually really really excited about.
I've talked about this before on stream.
Um.
But I'll be giving you guys a sample of what they've done.
Like this is not.
This is not the one that's being auctioned off.
But it's a sample of what they've done in the past.
So.
Oh my gosh this photo is huge.
Okay.
Alright.
This is a custom.
Uh.
Ball jointed doll.
Is 16 inches.
It will.
That's not the one that's being sold.
It's gonna be of me.
That's not me by the way.
I don't know if you noticed.
Laughing.
I know it's hard to tell.
I know.
It's almost the same.
But this is by Dolls Jewel or like Moonlight Jewel.
Um.
I am a huge fan.
Of custom doll making.
Um.
And it would be a Doki version.
A Doki Bird version.
Um.
I am increa...
I love custom ball jointed dolls in general.
I love like watching like.
Doll customization.
Like I like watched a lot of like Doll Lifeful.
In the past.
Um.
She's like one of my guilty pleasure YouTubers.
I love it when they do like.
They customize like Monster High dolls.
And stuff like that.
It's so interesting to watch.
I've actually like before.
Um.
Like 5 years ago.
I was like actually looking to commission.
A Doki.
Ball jointed doll.
For myself.
Like 5 years ago.
I remember just looking up.
Doll customizers.
Those who like customize Monster High dolls and everything.
And um.
And I recently started watching Moonlight Jewel.
Because they've done a lot of like.
Doll customization.
Similar doll customization.
Um.
It's honestly really interesting.
To watch.
Because it's like increa... very creative.
What they do.
And it's like.
Um.
I feel like doll customization is.
Like you know.
It's like very difficult to do.
Because you gotta know how to make clothes.
You gotta know how to customize dolls in general.
And then know how to like.
Draw on the eyes sometimes.
Or like do like custom.
Like painting on the faces and makeup.
And stuff like that.
It's actually crazy.
Um.
So like honestly.
It is a huge.
Work of art.
And I was very honored.
That Moon Jewel.
Moonlight Jewel.
Wanted to join the auction.
Uh.
Very beautiful.
It's honestly.
Um.
One of these types of arts and crafts that I really admire.
And uh.
I love watching doll customization.
In general.
So yeah.
Wooo.
Huge shout out to Moonlight Jewel.
Alright.
Next item.
It's another plushie.
Yeah.
I mean to paint the eyes is hard.
You also have to deal with like.
Doki.
Doki Amber Doge.
What are you doing?
You're not allowed to have chicken don't you?
You know.
Okay.
The best part is that I don't accidentally say the wrong name this time.
Doki.
I think that was like.
The hardest thing for me.
Like.
Doki.
Hi dad.
Amber Doge.
Um.
You know I have chicken.
You know.
You're not allowed to have chicken.
You're allergic.
How much.
How many times I've told you.
You're fucking allergic.
He's like.
I don't care if I'm allergic.
Okay.
Alright.
My dad came in and was like.
No.
Cause he was like.
You.
My other dad.
The human one came over and was like.
Here's some dog treats.
Alright.
Next item.
It is another plushie.
Where is it?
This one.
Oh my gosh.
So tiny.
Another plushie.
Okay.
We have one.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Nine.
Nine more to go guys.
We're almost there.
Introducing this whole thing.
This has.
This is a two hour intro by the way.
Oh my god.
Welcome to the two hour intro.
To this whole event.
Oh my god.
Very good time management.
Um.
Plushie number two.
Three.
Sorry.
I lost count.
I can't even count anymore.
This one is by Febublushie.
This is twenty seven years tall.
Um.
Also I love how they have like the earrings too.
Like the clip on the top.
I wear clip on earrings cause I don't actually.
By the way.
You guys didn't know this.
I wear clip on earrings cause I don't have my ears pierced.
Like.
I actually.
This is actually finished as well.
So it will be like shipped to you guys.
Um.
Instantly.
Within two weeks it will be shipped to you guys.
Um.
And I think the hat is removable.
I believe.
So I can be bald.
Um.
So.
So I can be bald.
So you can remove the hat as well.
Um.
Shit.
What was I gonna say?
Fuck.
Okay.
I forgot.
I wanted to say something.
But I forgot.
Okay.
Anyway.
Oh yeah.
About the earring.
I actually do not have my ears pierced.
Um.
I'm scared of pain.
And that is why I refuse to have anything done to my body.
Cause I am a little bitch.
So I do not have my ears pierced.
I um.
I wear clip.
This is a clip on earring.
Uh.
No tattoos.
No piercings or anything.
Uh.
It's just.
No holes.
.
I am.
Okay.
The funniest.
The worst part.
Is that.
I.
I buy.
You know like B-Show.
Lovely.
Uh.
The jewelry company.
Not sponsored by the way.
Like actually.
I really enjoy their products.
But.
They've done like jewelry collaborations.
With.
Uh.
With like.
Madoka.
I talked about my love for Madoka.
Many times.
I was like.
I still am quite fucking obsessed.
With Madoka.
And basically.
Um.
They released.
I basically brought their entire.
Fucking merch.
Jewelry line.
For.
Uh.
Madoka.
I mean I could show.
Not sponsored.
I really enjoy their products.
So.
Here's some free advertising.
But if you ever.
Wanna collab.
Well.
You can message my manager.
Yes.
Please.
Talk about sponsorships.
On your fucking charity stream.
Anyway.
Look.
There's always time to shill a little bit.
There's always.
This is um.
I do enjoy their products.
Okay.
I've been like.
Buying their stuff for a while.
Okay.
Alright.
Anyway.
As I was saying.
Uh.
I know this is not.
This is.
What I'm gonna show next.
Is not.
Is not going to be on the auction.
I just wanted to show you guys.
This.
To tell my story.
This is not in the auction.
By the way.
So basically.
I bought.
They had like a lot of other.
Merchandise stuff.
But I bought this entire set.
I can't wear it.
Because.
My ears are not pierced.
I bought.
The entire.
I bought everything.
Basically.
Like they had a lot of stuff.
They had like necklaces.
They had rings.
I also.
And then I.
They also.
Not in the auction.
This is just part of my tangents.
Just so you guys know.
This is not in the auction.
So.
I bought like.
The entire line of Madoka.
Even this.
Even.
Even though I don't have.
My ears pierced.
I also bought.
This because it's just so beautiful.
And like.
That is like.
The extent of my love.
For Madoka.
Like.
Only the Madoka series.
I don't give a fuck about like.
The spin offs.
Like the one.
I don't remember.
Rebellion?
No not rebellion.
The one where they're in another city.
And then there's like.
Rip off Madoka.
With a hood.
Like.
Fuck that version.
The.
The gotcha Madoka.
I don't know.
Record?
Not the same.
I'm sorry for people who actually like.
The gotcha.
Like rip off version of Madoka.
Not the same.
And I apologize.
To all the people that spent.
Thousands of dollars on that gotcha game.
Only for them to shut it down.
This is why.
You spend it on charity instead.
Not my Madoka.
Anyway.
But like I said.
Yeah like.
I don't care about the spin offs.
I just care about.
The original.
Alright.
Next item.
Where are we?
Oh this one's a fan favorite.
I believe.
I believe this one is.
A fan favorite.
It was so funny cause we were.
Um.
Someone said during the member stream.
When I was showing like previews of the auctions.
People in the member stream.
Actually seen some of these products already.
So now they're just getting a two hour.
They like paid for no ads.
For like in the member stream.
And now they're getting like.
An unskippable two hour ad.
Cause they're like.
We've already heard about this.
In the member stream.
And now to hear this again.
Hahahaha.
Okay.
Anyway.
As I was.
As I was saying.
We have the next product.
On here.
Is.
Ba-dum.
The tomato dragoon plushie.
Uh.
We got the same.
As twice.
Hahahaha.
I got.
Alright.
We have a tomato chonk goon.
Uh.
Uh plushie.
And this is obviously completed.
This is by kittyplushies15.
Um.
And look at this fucking.
Monster.
Of a tomato goon.
Look at it.
Hahahaha.
He's like.
He's like a shiny.
But instead of a shiny variant.
You're a tomato.
The shiny variant of.
Dragoons.
Is basically they're shaped like tomatoes.
And they're very rare.
Because majority of the time.
When a tomato goon is born.
They usually don't live past.
Past baby.
Because like usually all the dragoons.
Just eat it.
Because it's a tomato.
Or I eat it.
So like if a tomato goon lives past.
Baby mode.
Um.
They are like.
They are very rare.
It's very very rare.
Because they're like.
They're so harvestable.
Hahahaha.
God.
Look how harvestable you are.
Hahahaha.
So.
So it's very lucky.
That they are able to.
Live past baby mode.
Um.
And enjoy a very scary life of adulthood.
Uh.
Anyway.
But yeah.
This is tomato.
They're like dodos.
They're the dodos of the goons.
Basically.
Hahahaha.
They're the dodos of the goons.
Uh.
Alright.
Next up.
Oh this one I really like.
This one is.
This sculpture is so fucking cute.
I'm super obsessed with this outfit too.
Hahahaha.
The next item.
Is another.
Figure.
Um.
Of.
Me in.
This fan favorite outfit.
Uh.
This one is by.
Littlest Gifts.
It is done.
So of course that means it can be shipped within two weeks.
Uh.
So if you win this auction.
You get it.
Um.
You are able to receive it.
Quite fast.
Uh.
So this one is around.
13 centimeters.
Tall.
And it has like.
I love the base though.
The base with the little stars and everything.
It's so fucking cute.
Um.
But I know this is obviously a fan favorite.
From everybody.
Like everyone.
People really love this outfit.
It is also a really cute outfit.
I honestly.
It was one of my favorites as well.
So.
Uh.
But yeah.
Another really cute sculpture.
That I also will own.
Um.
But it's still one of a kind.
In public circulation.
For those who are.
It's still.
It's still considered one of a kind.
Do not worry.
Alright.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
7!
Top 7 left!
Alright.
Plushie number 4.
Where is.
Plushie number 4!
Alright.
This is another outfit.
I feel like I have.
I think all the plushies have like all my outfits in general.
So.
Plushie number 4.
By Luna Noctu Arts.
Um.
Well known plushie artist.
Within the Vtuber community.
Uh.
This is around 30 to 35 cm tall.
This one is not done yet.
Obviously.
But.
Another plushie to look forward to.
It's really.
I think that's 30 to 35 cm.
So that's pretty tall actually.
But.
They have made a lot of plushies.
Within the Vtuber community.
So you might recognize the work they have done.
And yeah.
This is another.
I believe the hat is removable.
Okay.
Actually I shouldn't say it.
I was just like.
But it was never removable.
What do you mean?
I don't know if the hat is removable.
Okay.
It could be.
But if it isn't.
I won't force them to make it removable.
So it's like.
Troll Ginger's hat.
Can it or can it not be removable?
It is to be decided.
I just add DLC.
They are like.
Oh shit.
I have to redo the pattern now.
You gotta buy it to find out.
Exactly.
If you really wanna know.
I guess you just have to buy it.
I mean.
I guess if that's what it takes.
You just have to buy the hat to find out.
Alright.
Sorry I have to take a sip.
Of my drink real fast.
Alright.
Next up.
I think we have two more plushies left.
And then also other stuff.
The last two plushies.
And then we have other things.
It's not the last two items.
We have two more plushies left.
Alright.
This is Tiny Mii.
Tiny Doki Plushy Kitchen.
By Squeaky Neko.
Yeah.
The post intermission.
Is just me sipping on some tea.
It's 3.5 inches tall.
It's very fucking tiny.
But it is a keychain.
And it's honestly incredibly cute.
Like look at that.
It's the hat.
Okay.
This one.
I can safely say.
That the hat is definitely not removed.
It's not removed.
Just so you guys know.
This hat.
Is definitely not removable.
So it's not false advertisement.
Because I know for sure.
It's not removable.
So.
That's all I have to say.
Okay.
Doki Amber Doge is mad right now.
Let me in.
Okay.
Where was I?
The last plushy in the showcase.
There's more guys.
There's not the last item.
There's a lot more.
There's four more items left.
It is.
A little dragon.
This is by.
Seracinia.
This is.
10 centimeters tall.
I believe.
It comes with.
The back side has a little.
It's so fucking cute.
I can show you it's back.
This is what it looks like.
In the back.
You can see the little butt tail over there.
And yeah.
You get to own a little tiny dragon.
Look at him.
You can fucking.
Punch.
I was like.
Doki.
Don't say your intrusive thoughts.
I know you want to.
Don't say it.
Anyway.
You can.
Throw it against the door.
Look at him.
He's so.
Throwable.
It's like.
Okay I almost said.
Some South Park thing.
You can.
Kick the dragon.
You know.
Just like in South Park.
Back when like Playstation.
One is like.
Super popular.
I mean all the Playstation are super popular back in the day.
But like.
Um.
My.
You know like.
Okay.
All you boomers out there.
Like.
Okay.
This is like my dad's thing.
Cause he was.
He is still a gamer.
Like he's literally playing Dying Light right now.
I think he's replaying Dying Light.
I don't know.
He's play.
I'm pretty sure he's replaying one of the Dying Light games at the moment.
Anyway.
On the PS5.
Anyway as I was saying.
Um.
You know like.
Okay.
For those zoomers out there.
Who didn't.
Back in the day.
Zoomers and Gen A.
Gen Alpha.
Back in the day.
We don't buy games digitally.
I know it's crazy.
Hahahaha.
There was no.
Steam back then.
Hahaha.
Hahahaha.
I know.
Back then valve.
Used to make video games.
Fucking I know.
It's so crazy.
Steam the creators of Steam.
Used to make video games.
Hahahaha.
Anyway.
Anyway, so my dad... so like back then, like PlayStation 1 games, people don't put the games in the... in the...
boxes.
They put the... instead... instead they buy these like giant CD holder things.
They buy these giant CD holder like contain... not containers, but like those flippy things.
Um, the TF2 had updates insane.
I know.
So my dad, his PlayStation 1...
His PlayStation 1 like game... Yeah, CD wallets.
Is that what you call?
Is that what you boomers call?
Yes.
CD wallets.
So that, um...
I feel that our dad is my age!
Don't think that!
Don't think that or I'll tell you how old PlayStation... did you guys know?
Guys that the PlayStation... okay, when did the PlayStation 1 come up?
The PlayStation 1 came out in 1994.
Holy shit!
That's like...
Hell yeah.
Uh...
That's like 30 years ago!
Holy fuck!
Okay, I had to think.
That was 30 years ago!
Oh my... okay.
Alright, anyway.
Anyway.
Anyway, so my dad, my dad's CD wallet was actually the South Park's kick the baby thing.
So like, I was... I would... when I would play around... like...
The thing is, my entertainment... um... my entertainment...
When I was like, you know, a fucking baby... was like...
Was like playing with the CD wallet.
Hahaha!
I would be like... I would be playing on the PlayStation.
Because it was like, they kick the baby, and you got... you squished the baby around...
in this like, liquid con... like, things in the front, and then my eyes were like...
Like, oh my god, this is like, so fun.
I wouldn't play the actual PlayStation 1 games... in the day.
I would just play with the CD wallet, I've kicked the baby, like it was... it...
It was like a fucking core memory of mine of me just squishing a baby around.
Anyway, next item on the list.
Sorry for this random ad there for all of you guys.
The next item, it is...
A Doki themed necklace!
Alright.
This is a concept art, but it is also made of sterling silver.
This is a Doki themed necklace.
So it has...
Obviously it's like in my colors with the gems and everything as well as like the design as well.
I remember I picked the con- they gave me several designs.
And I feel like this was the one that best represented...
Me.
And it is by Illycia.
So really beautiful necklace.
I really love like...
I really love like the design concept in general.
They're amazing.
A jewelry designer.
And it's really pretty.
It's inc- it's gorgeous honestly.
Like honestly, there's not a lot for me to say, because it's just a really beautiful piece.
And like I said, it is one of a kind in public circulation.
I hate that I can't say one of a kind anymore!
Not allowed to say one of a kind!
Anyway... anyway... alright... what is next?
Ooh, we are three more to go!
Three more to go!
Where is this one?
Where the fuck did I put the concept for this?
Uhhh... okay, here we go.
I think it is... this.
Alright!
This is a Doki themed pyrography linking wood.
So for those who don't... this is by Wyrmwood Pyro.
So for those who don't know what pyrography is, it's basically like flame torched art.
Which is crazy to think about.
So, if you look at their portfolio, I believe my mod...
Yeah, my mod has linked their portfolio.
And you see what they've done in the past and everything.
So they're using fire to create art.
So they draw it on the wood with fire.
And it's actually... their portfolio is insane.
It's actually very, very interesting to look at.
But very gorgeous artwork.
Indeed, obviously, it's concept art.
But I'm pretty sure it's going to turn out amazing.
But yes, it is like wood burning type deal.
So that is...
Okay, last two guys!
We're in the final stretch!
Our two hour ad is almost done!
Then we can go to the stretch goals for another ad break!
For a different type of ad.
Alright!
Next up!
Two Doki Bird signed prints!
Almost hot sauce time!
We're almost there!
Hot sauce!
Okay, alright.
This is two Doki Bird prints.
And this artist is...
Ba-bam!
This is by Hiso-mean?
Hiso-mean?
Um...
It's two signed Doki Bird prints.
Beautiful artwork, okay?
Honestly, gorgeous artwork.
And they actually gave me two work in progress.
Like I said, this is just a draft.
Obviously, it would...
There would be...
It's going to be refined a bit more later.
But here is their other...
Uh...
This is their other print that would be sent to you guys.
So this is the...
The two prints that would be there.
Yeah, this is the draft.
It's just a rough draft of the illustration.
Um...
And it will be signed by me.
I will not...
Okay!
Alright.
If this print...
If the auction for this goes to 2000...
Actually, I don't...
I feel like you guys would be like, No, don't cover the belly.
It's going to be like, I will sign my name on the belly.
But then I feel like you guys would be like, No, you ruined it!
Okay.
If it gets to 2K...
I will...
I will let you choose where I sign...
I will sign my signature.
I don't know.
Maybe you would want me to sign on the...
Do not ruin the stomach.
Don't cover the belly!
No!
If it gets to 2K...
I will let you pick where I sign...
Or I don't know...
Well, it would be a shame if my hand gets there.
Okay.
Anyway.
Anyway, we will...
Okay.
Last item.
The last...
The last item...
That's kind of evil.
Hey!
It's charity.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Last item.
Finally!
The last item...
Is a custom wood keyboard.
It comes with the key caps.
Yes.
So, it is a...
It has a dragoon printed on the keyboard itself.
You will see in the back as well...
There is a little dragoon in the back.
Oh, he's doing okay.
He's...
He's okay.
He's currently the top bidder and no one's sniping him yet.
So he's fine.
I say yet because he still has like 22 hours.
Someone in Asia might come over and be like, I'm sorry.
So basically it is a full wooden keyboard with dragoon prints on it.
And it comes with the keycaps.
34 minutes ago.
He's doing fine for now.
Yeah, he's doing okay, guys.
Nothing to worry about.
He is doing a-okay.
He just has to make sure nobody on the other side of the world wakes up and was like, ooh.
That's all you have to worry about at the moment.
All right.
Holy fuck.
Okay.
We took this a while.
But we finished introducing every single item that is in the auction.
Like I said, a huge thank you to...
It's not hot sauce time.
We go by order.
We go by order of the goals, guys.
It's not.
Hot sauce time.
We still have to do this.
We have to figure out the rest of the stretch goals.
And then we go by order.
Okay.
Time for the next ad.
Time for the next ad break.
Let's have a little intermission first.
Let me drink my fucking tea.
Okay.
As I was saying.
I want to say, like I said, a huge thank you and a huge shout out.
To all the amateurs.
To all the amazing creators that are part of this auction.
We couldn't have done it without everybody that applied.
Thank you to everyone that applied.
I'm really sorry if you didn't make it to the auction.
If you weren't able to be part of the final round that we chose for it.
Maybe in the future.
Because definitely, obviously I won't do these types of auctions very frequently.
Like, you know, it's going to lose their spark and their appeal for charity.
But maybe it'll be something I can do.
And I'll do again, maybe next year.
Because it was a great pleasure to work with lots of amazing creators.
To create these one-of-a-kind Doki Bird items.
So, good luck to everybody who wins it.
It is very competitive as we've seen.
Like, just from the first two hours.
We have...
We have reached, like, what?
$60,000?
I'm pretty sure more than $60,000.
Like, if anybody has kept...
That anyone kept count of, like, how...
How much...
So, well, nice.
$69,000.
We've, like, almost made $70,000 from just the...
From just the auction alone.
So...
And it's just the first two hours, too.
It's just the first two hours of the auction.
So, like I said, it's absolutely fucking crazy that we've came this far.
Alright!
It's time to add the stretch goal!
Alright, alright!
Alright, guys.
I will finally look at the stretch goal.
We have to figure out the rest of the goals now.
We have to figure out the rest of this.
Okay!
Alright, let's see.
Okay, $50,000 and $60,000.
Okay, let me bring up my list.
Alright, guys.
This is a list we made in the...
During the members.
So, you can blame the member goons if you think it's a...
If you think the list should be better.
Yeah!
You can blame it on...
They brainstormed this.
They brainstormed this, okay?
You can blame them if you think, like, it could be better.
I'm trying to find...
What do you mean, stop, stop?
I'm, like, deleting stuff to see the ones I've already put.
Okay.
Alright, let's see.
Let's see.
We've done that already.
We've put that in.
I've put that in.
Alright.
Okay.
This is not a lot on the list, I've realized.
Because...
I just...
I've realized...
I've already inserted majority of the...
Yeah.
Okay, we're gonna...
We're gonna come up with new things for the stretch goals, okay?
We're gonna come up with more things on the stretch goals, okay, guys?
Because I already, like...
Alright, here is what I have left.
Okay.
This is...
This is all I have left.
We're on the list we have.
After deleting everything.
Because all the other stuff is already on.
All the other stuff is already on the fucking stretch goals.
So it's not my fault.
It's not my fault.
Alright.
I see a lot of Mr. Mad.
Look, I didn't ask him to.
But, like, I...
He's literally on my payroll.
So, like...
Like...
I...
He's...
I literally pay him...
To do stuff.
So...
So, like...
I know I didn't ask...
For his permission.
I...
I didn't...
I didn't ask for his permission to be put...
Used as the...
But it's for charity, though.
It's for charity.
So...
Doki, do not...
What I'm saying...
All it is...
It is for charity.
Look...
As a great boss, I am going to volunteer my manager to do an ASMR...
Okay, okay.
I'll message it.
Hey, are you down to do an ASMR stream on my channel for charity?
For charity?
Okay.
I'm going to...
Alright.
Look...
See?
I asked him.
And it was very nicely asked, too.
I was like, hey, are you down to do an ASMR stream on my channel for charity?
And he can't pretend that he's not here.
Because I...
I can literally see that he's listening to something on Spotify.
I know whenever Mr. Man is online...
Because he would listen to something on Spotify.
And I would be like, he's online.
So he can't pretend.
Oh!
He said yes!
Alright.
That's going to be...
I'm putting that in.
He said yes.
Alright.
I'm changing to 50k right now.
50k is Mr. Man ASMR stream.
There you go.
Alright.
That's 50k.
And then 60k would be...
That is...
I will get forklift service.
I will get forklift certified.
There you go.
Alright.
That is my 60k.
And then we'll make one for...
We'll make one for 80k.
And then it jumps to 100k.
Because I'm going to run out of stuff to give you guys.
So...
What do you guys want for 80k?
You guys can come up with new goals too.
Because like...
I'm...
We've already fucking...
Chose a lot of stuff.
You guys want different things.
We can also do that too.
Alright.
We already have the Doki Bird ASMR.
We already have that.
Alright.
We already have the karaoke.
It's on.
We already reached it guys.
We already...
We already reached it.
Okay.
I know...
Alright.
I can't say like 24 hour streams.
Because like I know my fucking limits.
And that is a hard limit.
I cannot survive on 20...
Streaming 24 hours.
I actually like...
I cannot do that.
Like I remember trying to one time.
And it was like...
It was not good.
At all.
Okay.
Alright.
At...
Okay.
Wait.
Let me think.
I'm trying to think.
12 hour stream?
Okay.
12 hour stream is like...
That...
Alright.
I have an idea.
Okay.
At 80k.
By...
On...
What is it?
April.
Okay.
80k.
Wait.
We already reached 80k.
Never mind.
Okay.
80k.
We are going to...
My parent mom came in.
She's like, we are going to leave now.
And I was like, okay.
Alright.
Uh...
Guys.
I'm not going to make my dad stream.
He doesn't know what's going on.
What?
Okay.
Alright.
If you guys want...
Warrior...
Total.
For auction.
Okay.
What is the total?
For...
Auction.
And...
Uh...
And this.
Guys.
What is the total?
What is...
It's 120k right now?
Okay.
At 150k.
I will convince...
My dad...
To stream.
On...
On his PS5.
I'll convince him.
I'll convince my dad to do a PS5 stream for you guys.
But it's going to be in Chinese.
No.
Not...
Not Doki Amberdoge.
Guys.
Okay.
My dad will stream on his PS5.
Good for you.
My hu- Okay.
Human Dad.
I'll put that at 150,000.
Okay?
At 150,000, you will get that.
You will get that.
Where do you have it?
200k.
200k is Pokemon Smash or Pass.
Because he doesn't fucking play on PC.
He plays on the PS5.
He doesn't play PC games.
He plays on his PS5.
Guys, it's different.
A cover with Ditto?
Okay.
We already had 80k.
Fuck it.
We'll do it.
Duet cover.
Duet cover with Ditto.
I didn't ask her, but she's totally down.
Because we wanted to do it for a while.
We wanted to do it for a while.
She's totally down, though.
She's totally down.
It wasn't for charity.
She was...
Oh yeah, by the way, Mr. Man is asking you guys, how does ASMR work?
Does...
Does... Should he buy the ears?
Do you think he should buy the...
Just the one-off?
The one-off?
He gets the fucking ear... the ear mics and stuff for the one-off?
The full set... Mr. Man manages you.
For your streaming career.
Manager RP.
Oh my god.
2k!
Guys, I am not giving Mr. Man $2000 for this one stream.
There's no fucking way.
He's not even a streamer.
I am not giving Mr. Man $2000 for just one stream.
Manager RP.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh shit, wait.
My graphic designer finished like a little...
Graphics tab for the hashtag.
Let me...
Let me download that real quick.
Let me be more professional, guys.
For those who are like, Whoa!
What is your hashtag?
Let me add that on real quick.
Guys, I wanna be more professional.
Let me add the...
The hashtag graphic so you guys would know that this is the hashtag.
Okay.
There we go.
Whoa!
Wait, where is it?
Oh my gosh, it's fucking...
Huge.
Okay, here we go.
Guys!
If you guys were wondering...
Guys, this was the hashtag.
For those who don't know...
This is the hashtag.
For those who were confused...
I wish I wanted to make sure it wasn't covering anything.
Sorry for the name on the side that I'm covering.
For those who didn't know...
This is the hashtag.
Professional streamer here.
Alright.
Where was I?
Okay.
Alright.
We have...
Some of the stretch goals made.
Is that enough?
Is that good enough?
Alright, we got 60k forklift certified duet cover with Ditto.
Who I know is totally fucking down.
Guys.
Guys, she is fucking down for this.
I know for sure.
Guys.
Alright.
We are at 150k.
Because we're currently at 120k, right?
We are at 120k dollars raised.
I don't know what else to do.
What else do we do?
Is there any other stuff?
Can we change the 100k probably?
What are you...
You can't just be like...
There's no backsies for this guys.
There's no like...
Backsies.
Can I change that please?
Alright.
At 250...
Because we're already at 120k.
Right?
Okay.
We're at 120k.
120k.
Okay.
100 and...
Wait.
Where are we at?
Fuck.
Okay.
We're at 120k.
Do we have 250k yet?
250k.
I will...
Uh...
What's on my list?
Okay.
I will...
I will open commissions...
On stream for insert Pokemon here.
Poke...
It's the...
There you...
It's just gonna...
It's just gonna be a Poke...
I can't fit more!
Alright.
There you go.
These are...
Are...
Okay.
Let's actually go through all the stretch goals you've accomplished.
Let's all...
Let's all go through the stretch goals you've all accomplished.
Chat picks Twitter profile picture for two weeks.
Okay guys.
I'm gonna tweet it out.
Um...
The one...
The...
The picture...
That has the most likes...
Will be my Twitter pro...
Within Twitter TOS by the way.
Because I know...
People in the past who've done this...
The people in the past who have done this...
Actually got locked by Twitter.
Because...
The Twitter profile...
Because they got reported...
And people reported them...
And they got locked out of their Twitter account.
Because it was against terms of service.
I know...
Elon Musk...
Owns Twitter now.
And he's very relaxed about Twitter rules.
But...
Apparently...
Twitter profile pictures...
Are very strict.
For some fucking reason.
Compared to the other stuff in the Twitter TOS.
So...
I will...
Tweet it out right now.
I'm gonna tweet it out.
The picture...
With the most likes...
Um...
Okay.
How did I used to do it?
Um...
Reply...
With...
A picture...
For me to use...
As a...
Profile picture...
For two weeks.
The one with the most likes...
Becomes...
My new profile picture.
There we go.
I'm gonna...
Tweet it out.
And within...
Doki Ambidoj.
What is it?
I know there's chicken.
I know.
You can't have any.
No.
That's fucking right.
Okay.
Reply with a picture for me to use as a profile picture for two weeks.
The one with the most likes becomes my...
The one with the most likes wins.
Okay.
There we go.
Alright.
Here we go.
I'm gonna tweet it out.
Good luck guys.
Good luck.
May the best picture win.
I'm gonna...
Did people already have a picture?
How do y'all have a pit...?
Who the fuck put a tomatoes ass?
How the fuck do you already have a picture?
All right.
Here's the tweet.
Go wild.
Go fucking wild with your...
With your ideas.
All right, all right.
One stretch goal.
Done.
Next one.
Announce who you new papa is!
Yes!
Alright, so my mama will be a secret until my skin suit is done.
But I did get permission.
Unlike the ditto cover.
Let me message ditto real quick.
Let me message ditto real quick about if she wants to do this.
Okay.
Alright.
Sorry,
she is also asking about a collab.
Secret collab.
Will be announced later.
It's for Charity.
Guys, I'm not gonna fucking blackmail her with Charity.
Not blackmail.
I'm not gonna manipulate her with Charity, guys.
I'll just be like, hey ditto, do you wanna do a cover with me?
Yeah.
Alright.
Alright, there we go.
Anyway.
It's not blackmail.
It's manipulation, which I will not do.
Just so you guys know, it's actually manipulation.
But I will not be manipulating anyone.
All I said was, will you do a cover with me?
I didn't mention that.
I did not mention Charity.
Okay.
Doki Amber Doge, what would you...
What do you know?
Alright, here we go.
Okay, what else?
Uh...
What else is on the stretch goals?
Alright.
Oh yeah, I was supposed to announce my pop-up.
Oh yeah, there's so many things to announce now that we've reached numerous stretch goals.
Okay.
My new papa.
Let me like grab their Twitter real fast.
Alright.
My new papa.
Let me like prop the...
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, and then I'll follow them too.
So now people will be like, whoa, it's official.
It's official.
It's not a secret anymore.
I've also followed them.
So that's when you...
Doki Amber Doge.
Please.
Also, they don't consented.
So yeah, cover approved.
Now it's official.
Anyway, where the fuck is the...
Okay.
Alright.
So my new papa.
You might recognize their work because the reason why I picked them as my papa was because they've done a lot of really amazing work.
And I really love the fluidity of their skin suits.
Especially like how well the mouth works.
Because mouths are for this...
I don't know if you guys know this.
But human mouths are like really hard to get right.
So that's why I asked if they were able to be my new papa and doing the laundry and the laundry of my new skin suit.
So this is my papa.
Yay!
Okay, I'll post their Twitter.
So you guys know.
Alright.
For those who are wondering what they've done in the past.
They've done their most famous...
Or like not...
I don't know if famous is the right word.
But their most well known rigging is the one for...
Lymu?
Or Lymu?
I think that Lymu...
Lymu which is the green ferret.
The green white ferret.
So they've done...
Celia has done a lot of amazing...
Amazing models or skin suits in the past.
And like I said their most well known one was Lymu.
And Lymu...
I'm so sorry.
For mispronouncing.
I'm...
Please be patient.
I'm a Vtuber.
They've also...
They've also done...
Stuff for...
Holostars as well.
So...
So that's why I am...
Very looking forward to...
Working...
Working with them.
For the...
For my new skin suit.
So yeah my new papa!
When will it be done?
I don't know!
Cause it takes time!
Guys I need you guys to remember this.
I was not really prepared for all of this.
So...
So yeah anyway.
That is my new papa!
And that's why I'm...
Super excited!
I don't know when...
Yes!
It will be tomorrow.
It will not be tomorrow.
Guys I don't even know when it will be.
Guys I just need you guys to know.
I don't even know.
Please.
I don't even know guys!
But that is...
Gonna be my new papa.
Anyway!
Alright!
Next...
Next sub goal.
Not sub goal.
Next stretch goal.
Merch giveaway!
Alright!
So...
Like...
I don't really know how to do this.
Alright!
I might need to ask little man's help.
If little man is...
Is...
Aware right now.
Or like awake and watching.
If you're not awake and watching little man.
I will message you.
I don't know who I'm telling this to if you're not watching.
But like...
I need to figure out how to do the merch giveaway.
On stream.
But...
I...
Oh!
Little man's watching!
Okay!
Little man!
Can you help me figure out how to do a merch giveaway?
Do we do it on twitter?
We can do it on twitter.
Okay!
Wait!
I...
We can do the classic!
Like him!
Or just comment.
Honestly...
You don't have to like and retweet.
Just comment.
Alright!
Actually, you should retweet.
Because apparently when doing twitter giveaways.
It's so fucking hard.
To...
It's actually so difficult.
To like...
Calc...
Like...
To like...
Grab random...
Like...
Usually they look at retweets.
Like those...
Those like bots that does like twitter giveaway pickers.
Like where they pick the people.
Please...
I will kick you out of my room.
Little man.
Help me figure out what's the best way.
Retweet?
Or comment?
Or like...
On twitter?
Or do it on stream?
Anyway.
I will be giving out...
Um...
Five...
Five bundles from the debut.
And five bundles from the Lunar New Year bundles.
So...
Um...
So like...
It's a lot.
Because like...
Um...
I feel like since there's a lot of you supporting.
Okay.
I know ten might not be a lot to give away.
But it's the bundle.
So...
Um...
It will be ten merch...
10 merch...
That I'll be giving away.
But...
I'll also...
We're figuring out how to enter.
Uh...
We're gonna...
We're gonna figure out how to enter this.
Don't worry.
Little man and Mr. Man are figuring this out for me.
Okay.
I'm gonna kick you out.
You've been naughty.
Okay.
Guys.
Give me a sec.
We got...
I got him.
He can't...
The thing is...
He can open doors now.
Like...
Okay.
He like...
Because my door fucking sucks.
All he does...
Is that he like...
Pushes the door...
With his paw...
Or his nose...
And he's like...
I'm here now.
Okay.
All right.
I'm
not picking up the fucking chicken.
All right.
Here you go.
He's...
He...
No!
All right.
Oh.
Here you go.
All right.
He...
He's out.
He did nothing.
What do you mean?
I'm trying to have a conversation.
Like...
He did nothing wrong.
All right.
Anyway.
Okay.
All right.
He's out of the room now.
He's out.
Justice for dad.
Bro.
The moment I like...
I just...
He picked him up.
He tried to go for the chicken.
He's like...
Oh my god!
I'm taller now!
I'm now in reach of the chicken!
I'm like, nope!
Nope!
Other way!
Out the door!
Alright.
Anyway.
As I was...
As I was saying...
He's like...
Oh!
I got the chicken!
Alright.
As I was saying... What was I saying?
But, okay.
Alright.
Let's pick out the next merch drop.
I'll give you guys... You guys give me four suggestions on the theme of the merch drop.
And I'll let you pick one product to be made in production in this drop.
So, that is the choices I'm giving you guys.
Most likely, it has to be...
Within...
So, like... The theme has to fit...
Obviously, I can't get it made in production really fast.
So, like... Just plus four months and then...
One, two, three, four.
So, July and after.
Guys, I can't do Easter.
I cannot do like...
I cannot do Easter.
Because it's way too soon.
The merch drop will come out...
In like... After...
Like with July and after.
Maybe after July.
So...
Okay.
There's summertime.
I see some...
Swimsuit.
Okay.
I'll say summertime.
Summertime.
We're not gonna be able to do this in St. Pat...
Wait.
When's St. Patrick's?
We're definitely not able to do this in St. Patrick's.
Alright.
Okay.
Tomato themed.
Fucking tomato themed.
Alright.
Summer.
Tomato... Okay.
Halloween is so generic.
Like, you gotta assume that I was gonna make a Halloween theme anyway.
Try to think like...
Try to expand your horizons, chat.
We need you to expand your horizons right now.
Think beyond...
Like the generic theme.
Okay.
Halloween.
Uh...
Oh, not Halloween.
Fuck.
Okay.
Now you're fucking with me.
Tomato!
Summer festival.
Or summertime.
Um...
Tomato.
Summer.
Um...
What else?
What else, guys?
We're not gonna make America as a thing.
Okay.
I will put America as I swear to God.
Like...
July 4th is literally the year of the...
It's literally my birthday!
You guys ready?
Yeah.
It's literally my birthday.
Okay.
Um...
Alright.
Okay.
We'll do America.
America...
No!
America's birthday was named after my birthday.
Okay.
They're celebrating my birthday.
Last one.
Tomato.
Summer.
America.
Alright.
What's the last theme you want?
And then we're gonna put it up to a vote.
It'll be up to a vote for all of you.
We're not...
I'm not gonna get fucking...
Despite EA having a group relationship with me, I do not want EA to...
I don't want to piss them off.
Okay.
Magical girl.
That...
Those are the four.
Those are the four, right?
You guys.
Those four.
And then after that, we can decide what specific...
And we vote for the item that you really, really want in the drop.
Alright.
Um...
Theme for merch drop.
Okay.
Tomato.
America.
Yeah, there could have been like cooking or like masquerade or like, you know, like, you know, like...
There could have been like very nice themes, but instead we got America tomato.
Okay.
Magical girl.
I don't even know what...
I guess we could do jewelry for magical girls.
Alright.
Here we go.
The theme for the merch drop.
Alright.
I will give you guys...
I'll give you guys like 10 minutes to figure out while we do the...
While we...
Talk about...
I can't...
Okay.
We're gonna have to do a poll for the chat picks do I cover what you saw.
By the way, I did get permission.
Just so you guys know, we do have permission to do a cover of you saw.
In case people...
In case people are like, did you ask you saw?
Thankfully, you saw was totally down.
Thank God.
Okay.
Um...
Anyway.
As I was...
Uh...
As I was saying...
What was I gonna say?
Fuck.
Okay.
I already lost my count.
Alright.
Uh...
Yes.
Summer can be like beach and...
Uh...
This is not bathtub.
It's a beach.
Sorry.
I just had to say that out loud.
It was like fucking plaguing my mind.
Anyway.
As I was saying...
Um...
I can't do the vote for the you saw cover yet.
Because obviously, uh...
We need to use the poll.
The poll is being used right now for...
You know...
For...
For the theme for the merch shop.
Um...
Anyway.
We are going...
Holy shit.
The meta poster is on 5k?
Oh my God.
You really like paper.
Holy shit.
I'm like...
Oh really?
I'm...
I'm like...
Wow.
Holy shit.
You know what?
Good for that guy.
Um...
It's...
Sorry.
Metal paper.
I'm so sorry.
I forgot.
Metal paper.
Oh my God.
I mean...
I'm not surprised that metal paper has like more people bidding on it than regular paper.
I'm not surprised about that.
Holy fuck.
Okay.
Anyway.
As I was...
Sorry.
I got like really distracted by the paper there.
Looking at it.
Um...
As I was saying...
Leaking upcoming projects and work in progress.
So this is something I asked Mr. Man.
Like there's like stuff I asked...
Like stuff I wanted to show you guys.
Like...
And stuff that Mr. Man said I can reveal.
Uh...
Obviously I can't reveal like everything about it.
But I can say like...
I can reveal like...
So, yes, this is Mr. Man approved.
Like we had to ask permission if I can reveal it on stream.
And they said yes, but only like parts of it.
But basically...
Drumroll please.
I sound like America is losing.
Alright, the first thing I'm gonna leak or announce...
Okay, I need to make sure I don't accidentally say the wrong thing.
I never read what I can say.
Okay, the first thing is that I will be at Anime Expo.
I can't reveal it.
I don't know how I'm gonna reveal in what way.
But I will be at Anime Expo.
Future details will be announced at a later time.
But this is what I can say for now.
This is what I can say.
This is...
But yeah, that's what a big...
It's like...
Soon.
Details regarding...
Sorry, Mr. Man was like, you can say this.
And I was like, okay.
It will be announced very soon.
Apparently.
Apparently very soon it will be announced.
The details of like how I will be at Anime Expo.
But I will be there.
That's all I can say for now.
So yeah.
For those who were thinking about whether or not to go to Anime Expo.
If you guys want to potentially meet me.
This could be your chance.
But yeah.
Anyway, that is the thing I can say for now.
Anyway.
Something else I can...
I can announce.
Or like not announce.
Sorry.
Or leak.
Is that I am getting a new intro made.
And I guess since we reached our goal.
I can show you guys the new intro.
I think...
I think a lot of people are gonna be pretty happy with this intro.
It's still a work in progress.
But I can show you guys the video of it.
Since you guys made it to...
You know since you guys...
Got it all the way to the end.
Got reached the goal.
I can show you guys the intro.
Alright let me see if I can pull it up.
Alright.
Where is it?
Okay.
Let me see.
Let me find it.
Okay let me like actually...
Okay give me a sec guys.
I wasn't ready.
To like show it to be honest.
I wasn't ready to show it.
So guys give me a little scuff.
I need to like find...
What I can replace right now.
So...
Give me a sec.
I need to find it.
Because it's somewhere.
Alright.
I think the volume is going to be very...
I'm so sorry if the volume is like incredibly loud.
I'm so sorry.
Alright.
Okay guys.
If the volume is incredibly loud.
I am so sorry.
I don't know where this is going to show up.
Alright let me just make sure I chose the right one.
Plushies thank you for 50 gifted chips.
Thank you.
Thank you again for joining the auction.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you.
Okay I think this is it.
Alright I'm so sorry if this is really loud.
I'm really really sorry.
I'm going to mute this song real fast.
Yeah!
That's right!
You guys didn't know that song is actually public domain.
Oh my god!
Bacon thank you for the 50 gifted chips!
Thank you!
Oh!
Um.
But yes!
That is being worked on at the moment.
I believe it will be done around maybe mid March or end of March.
It really depends on the animator.
I love working with this animator.
I've been working with them since for like 3 or 4 years I think.
I've always loved their work and I'm really happy to be able to keep working with them and to make a new intro!
Honestly my favorite part is like the dancing the dancing dragoon.
I love I just love to see the little dragoon just like hopping around.
He's like It's so cute!
That's honestly my fucking um my favorite part in the whole thing.
With the little stick legs!
Yeah!
It's so fucking cute!
Um but yes!
Huge shout out to Hoopyon.
Um I've always loved working with them.
And I was so happy that they would like to still work with me.
Um on this new intro.
And oh my gosh it's just so cute.
I ah it's honestly really fucking adorable.
Oh my god!
I love I just oh my gosh the little hops.
The little hops is just so good.
Richard!
Thank you for the 10 gift that's just Thank you thank you!
Um but yes look forward to that at the end of March where it will be uh where it will be released.
Where I will finally be able to use it.
Um I know um in the future it's definitely gonna get updated whenever I do getting new skins soon.
Um Hoopyon has uh has like blocked off a date.
So I will be able to use it a month uh general month to like rework on it later on in the future.
Uh to update it to update it if needed.
So um it might not be the one version of the intro.
There's gonna be more versions of this intro in the future.
So something else to look forward to.
So it might not be like uh whenever I do get the updated skin suit it the intro is going to look different.
Um but for now it's based off my current skin suit.
Yeah!
Like I'll still be using uh it will be basing it off of my current skin suit for now.
And then she's she's gonna edit it to update it in the future.
So yes that is I don't know let me see if there's anything else I can legally uh show you guys.
Um let me double check if there's anything else that I can um I mean I've talked about this before but the next big event slash project that I'll be working on I think I've talked about it in general but like I never said it officially but the next official project that I'll be working on that I've been in talks with Mr. Man about this um is going to be like this the next event I'm planning on.
Because this is like more so of a small scale you know like the hardest part of doing all of this was the auction in general.
But the next event that I'll be hosting um after this will be the uh VTuber WW uh sorry not WW the VTuber Wrestling Event.
That will be my next official event that I will be organizing.
Um after the charity.
So it's all still being planned and everything.
Like it's being like brainstormed at the moment on the logistics of everything that's going to be going on.
But the uh next big event I'm planning on will be VTuber slash wrestling event.
Hahahaha Hahahaha So that is my so it's sort of like for those who are like wondering what it's going to be like so it's sort of like WWES so like it's like Wrestlemania type deal.
Uh Uh So it's going to be like similar to that but for VTubers!
Uh and that is what I'm working on after this.
Obviously I was wanting to like work on multiple things at the same time.
But Mr. Mad and Lil Mad was like one at a time doki.
Hahahaha Hahahaha One at a time!
But like I was like I want to do everything!
No no no focus on your charity!
event doki!
Hahahaha So Hahahaha So that is that is the next event I'm planning on.
Hahahaha But what if I want to do everything!
No no no!
You gotta put all your energy on this for now!
I'm like okay I guess I will.
Hahahaha Hahahaha Um Okay also Let me ask Lil Mad they can make me a template.
Can you make me a tweet template?
It's so nice having assistance!
I give you for the give away.
Hahahaha It's so nice!
I'm like can you write my tweet for me for the giveaway?
While I talk to my chat.
Hahahaha Hahahaha Hahahaha Okay also wait let me see if I can announce this.
Give me a sec I'm gonna I'm gonna look at what they I'm gonna look at like okay.
Uh Oh!
Okay!
Yes!
Alright.
Um By the way okay this is not really like a big announcement or anything but like Apex Legends gave me like free codes to give away um to give away to people but it's like it's like I think like I think it's like um it's like Apex Coins and like the new like skins or stuff for um for the new event that's gonna for the new Beast Collection giveaway event and I'm allowed to give them away on the 4th.
So like I'm just gonna be like if you want to enter uh Hahahaha I'll tweet that out on the 4th.
But I'll just be like if you want to enter.
What do I make you guys say?
Cause last time I was like meow for me.
Hahahaha I was like meow for me kiddin.
Last time I did this.
No last time I did this I say meow for me.
I need to do something else for you guys to make you guys do something else embarrassing.
Alright.
Okay.
How do I embarrass the dragoons for free Apex Coins?
How do I What do I?
No no no.
If you had a persona what will it be?
Hahahaha Hahahaha We have no shame.
Alright.
Um.
Okay.
I'll do like reply with uh Hahahaha Hahahaha Hahahaha Alright.
I don't know.
I don't know yet.
I'm trying to figure out what to I'm trying to figure out like what to make you guys reply with Um.
For a chance to win a for a chance to win the giveaway code.
So I'll figure that out later.
I'll figure that out later for you guys.
Um.
Alright.
Let's see.
What else?
Is there an image of said merch?
Oh yeah.
I do.
Okay.
Let me give Oh.
It's It's in the server.
I'll just write that.
I'm too lazy right now to give it to them individually.
Hahahaha It's in the server!
Hahahaha I don't need a link.
I don't need a link.
It's in the server.
Um.
Oo for codes.
Oh yeah.
I did that.
That's good.
That's actually pretty good.
Oo for codes.
Alright.
Next up.
Okay.
Oh shit!
The tomato won!
I'm actually surprised.
I thought magical.
Okay.
The next It won't be the.
It might not be the next one.
But like it would be like we will have this.
So.
Oh yeah.
The background music was muted.
Whoops.
I didn't even realize.
Thanks for letting me know.
Alright.
So the next theme.
I need to write this down for myself.
Uh.
Buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh Okay.
Let me write this.
Hahaha Hahaha Okay.
Tomato merch drop info.
Okay.
I just wrote that in the server.
Just to remind myself.
Hahaha Hahaha.
Alright.
Tomato themed merch drop.
What is the one thing.
I will do one thing that you request.
Um.
What is the one thing that you guys want in the tomato merch drop.
What is the one thing.
A plushie.
Tomato.
Okay.
I will give you guys three things to vote for instead of four.
Tomato plushie.
What else?
And then you guys pick for the tomato.
They can't all have dakis.
I am not going to make daki makuras for everything.
I will put it there.
Tomato daki.
Tomato plushie.
Look.
Only one thing can win.
Guys.
Only one can win.
Hahaha.
I need you guys to know this.
Only one can win.
Hahaha.
I almost wrote tomato bundle for the giveaway instead of the letter.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
I am not fucking giving you guys a fresh.
Okay.
Alright.
I will.
Okay.
The tomato mouse pad.
Alright.
So you know it is like booba but like instead it is tomato.
So we are in the...
Hahaha.
Okay.
Only one can win in this poll though.
Alright.
Okay.
The requested item in the tomato themed merch drop.
Only one can win.
There will be other items in there but it won't be the others.
Alright.
Okay.
Tomato plushie.
Tomato dockie.
Tomato.
Hahaha.
It is like okay.
There is like this famous animal crossing booba mouse pad but instead of tomato it is like the animal crossing fruits and that is like what I am thinking of right now.
Hahaha.
That is actually what I am thinking of.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
The requested item in the tomato themed... Alright.
Let me see.
I am going to see if I can find... Pull it up.
Animal crossing...
Oh my god.
This is so... This is going to be so cursed.
This is going to be so bad if it doesn't show up the one that I expected.
Hahaha.
It is so bad.
Oh it is this one.
I think I actually...
I think I almost bought this one.
I am pretty sure I almost bought it because I was like oh my god this is so cute.
Hahaha.
But it is this.
Let me show you guys.
It is this.
So it will be like this but tomatoes instead.
Like it is like...
It is so cute though.
It is so cute.
Hahaha.
I actually...
I almost ordered this because I was so...
The thing is I would never use it.
I would never use it because I have a gamer mouse pad.
But like it is so cute.
But instead of the fruits it is the tomatoes.
But only if it wins of course.
It is only if it wins guys.
If you are like guys please.
We could have tomatoes.
Please.
Hahaha.
It is hard to vote for it because there is so many choices.
There is so many choices but only one can win.
Chat.
Only one can win and then the rest would be like...
There can only be one super high production item.
Because like I can't afford to make several super high production items.
Hahaha.
Guys.
So only one can win guys.
I will give you guys 5 minutes to vote for your themed item.
And then...
And then we will move on from there.
Okay.
What else?
What else can I show you guys?
Oh you guys want to see the next one?
The next Doki Bites short?
That is still being worked on?
I can show you guys that.
That one is really cute to show.
It is actually so funny.
Hahaha.
I will leak that one too.
I will leak to you guys the next Doki Bites animated short.
I am pretty sure this might be the one that is released next.
Judging by like how...
Judging by like the timeline of everything.
I am pretty sure this one is the next Doki Bites short that is being released.
That would be the last thing I will leak out for you guys.
Regarding everything.
That would be the last thing.
And we are going to move on to the next stretch goal.
Alright.
Let's see.
Is this the right one?
Yeah.
You might recognize this animator.
I am really happy to keep working with them.
Honestly.
Alright.
Let me turn off my mic.
Butter my biscuits.
What in tarnation do you want you colorful critter?
I am a woman.
My
apologies man.
What can I do for you?
Okay.
Alright.
Um.
Wow.
That is a very big gun.
I wish I could have a closer look.
Hahaha.
Now hold on there partner.
This here gun ain't no toy for jesters like yourself.
Best keep your distance and you know what's good for you.
So why don't you tell me what you really came here for.
Wow.
Okay.
Wait.
Wow sir.
Dangerous.
Huh?
I love danger.
Hahaha.
Actually negative risk.
Yeah.
Alright.
That was a little... Hahaha.
You might recognize that I worked with this animator multiple times.
I'm very happy to be able to keep working with him.
Hahaha.
I think my favorite part was like it's just like the x-ray vision on the tomato.
That's like my favorite part.
Hahaha.
It's like the inner doki.
Oh my god.
You recognized the voice.
I know.
It's so talented voice acting guys.
I'm so happy you guys are able to recognize the voice actor.
Hahaha.
Both voice actors are are incredibly talented.
I can't believe we were able to... I can't believe we were able to get them for the short.
Is that crazy?
I can't believe we were able to get them.
Hahaha.
It was very hard to hire a hire...
They really booked up on their work schedule.
So I'm just... Oh my god.
I'm just so happy it was possible guys.
I'm so happy.
She was a bit...
Oh my... What did he say?
Excuse me.
Hahaha.
Alright.
Okay.
Let me see what else... Let me see what else is on the stretch goal.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
Okay.
Buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh.
Alright.
We got the... We got the League of Coming Projects and Work in Progress.
We'll do a karaoke stream in March.
That I don't have to plan or anything.
ASMR stream.
That I don't have to plan.
Alright.
Bento stream.
Chat design.
Theme and design.
Okay.
That will need to be voted on.
God damn.
There's so many voted... Okay.
There's so many voted on stretch goals.
I did not think this through.
Hahaha.
Alright.
The winner is the tomato plushie.
So.
We will have the tomato plushie as... I think the bento thing I'm gonna make a hashtag for it.
As well as we will...
I'll make a community post for the bento stuff.
So, um...
So it lets me have time to think about it.
So like doing... deciding it right off the bat.
Because like bent... building bentos is not the only way to do this stuff.
It actually takes time for me to like brainstorm everything and grab materials.
So.
The bento stream.
The bento like ideas and all that stuff.
That will be decided in a community post.
Later.
Alright guys.
Instead of voting for stuff.
I will do the hot sauce.
Guys.
I...
I will do the hot sauce.
Hahaha.
Let me write down for myself.
I need to write down for myself tomato... I'm gonna put tomato plushie.
Let me...
tomato plushie.
Hahaha.
I need to write this down for myself.
Okay.
Alright.
I'll show you guys the hot sauce.
Okay.
I'm just gonna grab it off Google.
It's easier.
Cause like it's...
Hahaha.
The last...
dab...
experience.
Okay.
Alright.
This is 2 million.
By the way.
I need you guys to know.
That this hot sauce...
is 2 million.
Hahaha.
The basketball ad is finally finished.
This is only the intermission.
What do you mean?
We're back in ads.
Very soon after this.
This is just the intermission.
Okay.
Anyway.
Alright.
So...
This is...
This is the...
Over 91% pepper.
By the way.
Um...
Yay!
Alright.
So...
This is...
The hot sauce that I will be using.
It is 2 million.
Hahaha.
Alright.
I feel like...
Let me... I need to play...
A song that matches this.
Let me YouTube a song real quick.
I... I swear!
If they claim this song...
It's fine.
It's not even...
Like... This is a charity stream.
What if they claim it?
I just realized.
Wait.
This is a charity stream.
I don't give a fuck if they claim this.
Hahaha.
I almost forgot.
I was doing this for charity.
I was thinking about content.
I was thinking about...
Okay.
Is it... Alright.
It doesn't matter what song I play anyway.
As long as it's not blocked.
Is this song good?
Can the church copyright claim me?
I don't...
I swear.
If the church copyright claim me...
I swear to God!
I swear to God.
If the church copyright claim me...
Hahaha.
I swear to God.
Alright.
I'm gonna shake this.
Grabbing the chicken.
Okay.
Six minutes.
I have six minutes to...
Okay.
Jesus is not public domain.
Hahaha.
Jesus please don't kill my video.
It's charity.
Hahaha.
I'm so scared.
I'm
gonna...
Oh!
It has to be louder so I can like...
feel God.
Hahaha.
It needs to be louder.
I need God by my side.
Oh my God.
I need to wash my hands after this too.
I'm so scared.
Okay.
Oh.
Pouring the hot sauce on my chicken.
Ah!
Okay.
Pouring.
Just making sure I don't pour too much.
Oh my God.
What the fuck?
Oh!
That's too much!
Ah!
Oh my God.
It's so...
It...
I can smell how spicy this is.
Oh no.
Oh, I can smell the spice.
Oh.
I was not scared with the other hot sauce.
The other hot sauce were fucking weak.
But like, two million?
Two million is way too much million.
Two million is just too, too many millions.
The other ones were so weak, but two million.
It's 98% pepper.
Yes, this hot sauce is two million.
SHU.
Okay.
Please.
Stop!
I need a field!
Jesus!
Guys!
I'm not feeling the Jesus yet!
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Alright.
Three!
Two!
I can smell the pepper!
It's like, it's like 30 centimeters away from me and I still smell the pepper.
Okay, maybe 30.
20?
20 centimeters away from me and I still smell it.
Okay, maybe 30.
20?
20 centimeters away from me and I still smell it.
Okay.
Three.
Two.
One.
Oh my god!
I don't eat more chicken!
Milk is for pussies!
Oh my god!
Oh fuck!
Okay!
Okay.
I'm gonna sit with the spice for a little bit.
Oh.
Oh my god!
Okay.
I didn't...
Oh my god.
Fuck, okay.
I'm a pussy.
Oh my god, okay.
I should laugh.
Okay.
It actually tasted nice though.
Other than it being extremely spicy.
Oh my god, it's still burning.
It's still burning.
I would say...
It's very spicy.
It's like... I still feel the spice on my tongue.
I still feel it.
But there's flavor.
Fuck, okay.
Oh.
It's better than the bomb.
It actually...
It...
It... Like, it has flavor.
Like, that's all I asked for.
Oh.
But it's... Oh my gosh.
It's like... It's like... It's spilling.
I... I toler... It's... It's... It's very spicy.
Oh my gosh.
It's very... Oh my god, I can feel it in my cheeks.
What the fuck?
What's wrong with this pepper sauce?
What's wrong with this sauce?
Okay.
It's very spicy.
But it actually has a nice taste.
Will I do it again?
Honestly?
Honestly, if I have... I don't have enough milk.
I don't... I don't...
I literally only have like...
Two... I like... My milk is like barely done.
I only have like one more sip of milk left.
Oh, but... Oh my... Oh my god.
It's like pinching my cheeks.
I like feel like the pinch on my cheeks.
Oh my god.
It's like... I don't know... Okay.
It's like those spice that builds up.
It builds up and it's like pinching.
It's like pinching.
I feel like if you don't have the spice tolerance like me...
You're so fucked.
Oh my god.
Like I wouldn't say...
Like oh my god.
I'm gonna fucking die.
That's so fucking spicy.
I wouldn't say that.
I would say that I think it's very spicy.
But it's not like I'm gonna fucking die.
So if you don't have my spice tolerance...
You're so fucked.
Because even I was like damn that like I could feel like the pinching on my cheeks from the spice.
It's definitely not gonna be doing very well in my stomach.
Like at least I'm not like mixing all of it like last time.
That one was bad.
That was very bad.
But I would definitely say...
I grew up with spicy things.
So I live.
But like if you don't grow up with spice...
I don't know what to say.
I think you'd be pretty fucked anyway when you eat my chicken.
When you eat my chicken.
Hmm.
I deserve this.
I deserve my chicken.
Alright.
Now of course...
It's a non-sauce chicken.
I deserve more chicken.
But like not the spicy one.
Oh my god my eyes are watering though.
Holy shit.
I feel like it's not as fun when I have like the Asian spice tolerance though.
I have the Asian spice tolerance so like...
Oh shit.
Give me a sec guys.
I need to wash my hands.
I need to make sure I don't touch my eyes.
Give me a sec.
Alright I'm back.
Alright.
Alright like I said.
Fuck the Bamha sauce.
That shit tasted like metal.
Like I don't understand.
They can make perfectly reasonable sauce.
Sauce.
Hot sauce.
That actually tastes like something good.
But then they made the Bam which is just metal.
It just actually tastes metal.
Like the Bam was so fucking bad.
Holy shit.
But this one's like actually...
If it wasn't so fucking hot.
I would try it again.
I would try...
What is it called?
I would try the last dab experience.
Yeah.
If it didn't...
If it wasn't like...
I mean...
Okay to be fair.
If I had another...
If I had more milk.
I will actually do another bite.
I'll do another chicken for it.
But like I barely have enough milk for this.
So it's not worth it.
It's not...
It's not worth it.
So like I wouldn't...
I wouldn't fucking...
I wouldn't...
I would not like push that boundary.
Alright!
What's the next stretch goal?
What is it?
I haven't played a single game.
I've just been...
I hope you guys have been entertained.
Despite the many non-skippable ads.
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, let's see.
What's the next one that is...
Okay.
Um...
Duet cover with Yuuzhan!
So... um...
Yuuzhan is totally down to do it.
They were actually at first down to do it without the charity.
And then I was like, no, let's do it for charity.
Because, you know, it's a good cause.
Let me read... um...
Okay, so basically... um...
The duet cover...
Duet cover with Yuuzhan.
You guys get to decide what song...
Um... we can do together.
Um... and... uh...
Yuuzhan will be in charge with...
Getting the mixers...
And the instrumentals.
And then I will be in charge of finding the artist.
And the MV editor.
I will be funding...
I will be funding the entire video.
Uh... but... uh...
But we're like splitting the job.
So like I will still be paying for the instrumentals and mixers.
Um... but... um...
But like Yuuzhan will be in charge of finding them.
Because like, you know, they are a singer.
And they're much more experienced with that type of thing.
Um... so...
We will decide on...
Um...
Will you guys get to pick...
Uh... what duet cover we will do together.
Um... I will say...
If...
You know... um...
Guys, okay, this is very off topic.
But one of my fav...
Hahahaha!
This is super off topic.
But I don't know if you guys know this.
But one of my favorite songs is...
Def should not have taken thee.
Uh...
Hahahaha!
What?
This is just so off topic guys.
It's so off topic.
But I like to say that...
Um...
Def should not have taken thee...
Is honestly one of my favorite...
Um...
Uh...
Duet songs out there.
But...
Hahahaha!
Obviously, this has nothing to do with like the cover with...
With Yusam.
But I love, you know, Wonderful Opportunity is like one of my favorite...
Like JP...
Um...
Bookaloid artists.
And oh my god.
Hearing like...
Uh...
Hahahaha!
All I'm saying is that...
Oh my god.
Like you guys should totally...
Like listen to this song.
Hahahaha!
And like...
Oh...
It's just such a good song though.
Right?
Hahahaha!
I'm so sorry.
I got the whole right here, guys.
That would be great for a second cover, you know?
That would be great.
Hahahaha!
That would be...
So it's like...
Oh yeah...
Like for your second cover, right?
Like wow.
Yeah!
I'm just...
I'm just saying.
It's so off topic anyway.
Anyway...
As I...
It's super off topic though.
But like...
What...
What are your...
What songs do you guys want Yussan and I to...
What songs do you guys want Yussan and I to do?
Yes, yeah.
What suggestions do you guys have?
Okay, we cannot do Free Bird.
Because they already demonetized me the first time.
So I refuse to do Free Bird.
They already... Free Bird has generated enough revenue off of my first stream back.
Like, they have... I will veto Free Bird just because they've already generated enough income from that stream.
So I... I will veto Free Bird because of it.
I heard Roki.
Roki is a nice song.
Roki is a great song too for... for a cover.
Alright, Roki.
What other suggestions do you guys have?
We will have a poll with four choices just like last time.
And then you guys can vote for the one you guys want to hear the most.
Oh my god, why are you guys suggesting the fucking hardest songs that I would never be able to sing?
Like... guys!
You guys would sound amazing!
But you guys have to remember...
I am also singing it.
Like... I am also singing it.
Like...
What was it?
Usai?
Is that the... Is that how you pronounce it?
Like that... There is no fucking way I would be able to sing that.
Holy fuck.
You guys always sound amazing.
Alright.
Okay, let's see.
Oh!
Bro!
Thunderwear!
I like Death Should Not Have Taken Thee.
That is such a good suggestion.
Thunder!
Wow!
Thank you for suggesting that.
That is a really good suggestion.
For a song cover.
Oh my god.
What do you mean?
I was reading off chat!
Guys!
It's not rigged!
I was literally reading off chat!
Guys...
I don't know why...
I was...
I was reading off chat.
I don't know what you are talking about.
I literally...
Someone really wanted me to sing that.
Oh my god.
Thank you, Ma.
Just for linking that song.
That...
That is...
That is a good suggestion.
I would...
I...
I would gladly put that on the poll.
Paid out after...
I don't know what you are talking about.
I was just...
I was just reading off of the chat!
Guys!
What do you mean?
Everything was just read off of chat.
Alright.
Okay.
Guys.
It's Il Jon.
Oh wow! legitimacy.
Bro, there's no way I can sing that song!
lol.
No.
There's no way I can sing the last... Oh my god.
Ok...
Now there're songs that like I can actually be able to sing.
Guys... Guys!
I mean we can also do like...
Ummm...
Alright...
Guys, please...
Within my vocal range...
Chat...
I know you guys think I am very talented.
But like...
There's some things that I know...
I know...
I...
I really hate to break it to you.
But like...
I'm not perfect.
I know...
I...
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
I...
I know it's great!
I didn't want to say this.
But...
I am...
I'm not perfect.
I...
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
There have limitations!
I have limitations when it comes to singing!
I'm so sorry!
I didn't want to tell you this!
But I had to...
Before...
Oh, it's too late.
I'm sick.
Now the immersion!
You were supposed to be perfect Doki!
How could this happen?
Ponyo!
Okay.
I like that.
Oh my god, I can sing like the English cover too.
I don't know if you someone want to do that.
I love that song so much though.
Holy shit.
Alright.
Okay.
Nice.
Drop Pop Candy!
Wait!
Drop Pop Candy is pretty nice too.
Fuck!
Okay!
Drop Pop Candy.
Okay.
I'm sorry, but like my favorite version of Drop Pop Candy has to...
Okay, but like have you guys heard the Undertale version of Drop Pop Candy?
All I'm saying is that, not gonna lie, the Undertale version of Drop Pop Candy is pretty fire.
It's pretty fucking fire.
I mean, come on!
It's pretty good!
Like... it's pretty good.
Wait!
Okay, but what if we do...
The... Oh wait, but I don't know if Yu-san can sing in Chinese.
What am I saying?
I don't know.
I don't know if Yu-san can sing in Chinese.
Maybe not.
Cause I was like, oh hey, I need this.
That's a duet too.
That's a duet.
No!
I don't think Yu-san can sing in Chinese!
There's no... I feel like... I don't know.
Let's see.
I'm trying to think.
Okay.
Alright.
How about...
Dream... Dream Pop Candy?
Wait, was it Dream Pop Candy?
I don't really... I don't remember.
Was it...
Dream Pop Candy?
Uh...
That should not have taken thee.
Which, by the way, I think...
If Yu-san and I did that...
Song...
It would be... It would sound so good.
Okay.
I'm saying...
All I'm saying...
Okay.
Alright.
Anyway.
Duet cover.
With...
With Yu-san.
That should not have taken thee.
Uh...
This sounds like, please stop.
Was it Drop Pop?
I don't even remember if it's...
It's Drop Pop.
Yeah.
Oh, it's a Dream Pop Candy.
Okay.
Drop Pop Candy.
Rookie.
You know what?
We'll do these three.
Ponyo can be...
I feel like Ponyo wouldn't really fit, to be fair.
Uh... Alright.
Here we go.
Choose.
It is time.
It is time...
To pick.
Oh my God.
Who...
Guys!
Oh my God!
I can't believe it!
Guys!
I can't believe that should not have taken thee!
Is winning the vote!
Don't let her win, guys.
Holy shit!
I'm so surprised!
Guys!
Oh my God!
This is actually insane!
Who would have thought?
Can we go on straight?
You know, guys!
Guys!
Um...
I will give you...
I will give the poll to be up for, you know...
Maybe like two more minutes.
You know...
I mean one more minute.
Sorry, fellas.
I've got a sip.
Thank you, Keith.
That's why you're my favorite.
Alright, guys.
Oh my God!
It seems we're almost a minute up!
Guys!
Whoa!
Alright, don't worry, everybody.
I will do a little countdown.
I'll do it...
Guys, it's okay.
I'm gonna do a little countdown.
So we all know that this is all fair.
It's the fair vote, guys.
Just so you guys know.
Damn!
Oh, I can't believe we're doing...
I can't believe we're doing this song!
How do you guys know this was one of my favorite chat?
How did you know this was one of my favorite songs?
Oh my God!
That's fucking crazy!
I'll do a countdown, everybody.
So you can get your last minute votes in.
Ten!
Nine!
Eight!
Seven!
Six!
Five!
Four!
Three!
Two!
Look!
I'll even give you guys more time!
Two and a half!
Two and three quarters!
Two and five quarters!
I don't think that's how math works.
One!
Whoa!
Zero!
Oh my God!
Dev shouldn't have taken me!
Well...
If you guys say so...
I guess...
I guess we're gonna do this song!
Oh my God!
I can't believe it!
I can't...
I can't believe...
Dev should not take anyone!
Two and...
Four!
Five!
Six!
Seven!
Nine!
Ten!
One!
Three!
Two!
One!
Three!
It feels just like Helldivers, too!
Oh my God...
v cn actanter khng  I love that.
I love managed democracy!
Okay!
All right!
Nice!
Nice.
Alright, nice.
Okay, we got that stretch goal out of the way.
Welcome to America!
Don't you love it here?
Alright, I'm gonna see the poll.
I'm gonna see the Twi- I swear to fucking god.
Is this actually- I- Okay.
Apparently the...
The art of tomato bikini is winning the poll.
Is winning the...
Uhh...
Yep, it is.
Yep, it's the most- It's the most liked at the moment.
That is the current profile picture that has the most likes.
People are gonna be so fucking confused.
They're gonna be so fucking confused.
Alright, the next- The next one.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh my god, I've been streaming for like almost four hours.
That's like- I feel like that- No, five hours has been the longest I've ever streamed because of Batman.
Okay.
Let's see.
We have the next thing that is up.
Is...
What is it?
Chat decides the next outfit- Oh, sorry.
Outfit themed.
Four hour long ad!
I am trying my best here!
Oh my god.
Okay.
Anyway.
It could have been a five hour long ad, chat.
It could have been a five hour long ad!
Okay.
Anyway.
As I was saying.
The next- Chat gets to pick the next outfit themed.
Um...
New exist- Okay, guys.
Guys.
Okay.
Uh...
I will give you guys four choices to pick.
I see alternative themed.
Uh, that one's an official outfit already.
Like, it's not really- I guess like- I guess if you want to see me with that skin suit on.
Um...
Okay.
One is the alternative girl doki.
The alt- The alt girl doki.
The other one is- Okay.
I'm trying to see if there's another one.
Tomboy.
Okay.
Tomboy themed.
Alright.
What's the third?
There's two more choices for you guys.
Magical girl!
Okay.
Magical girl.
What's the fourth?
I'm trying to see which one has the- Which one- I'm trying to see which one is gonna- Um...
Which one?
The fourth, guys.
The fourth!
Or there's gonna be only three!
Alright.
You only have three, guys!
A lot of you guys are like different!
Steampunk?
Steampunk would be like- That would be interesting.
Actually.
That would be an interesting one.
Okay.
I'm gonna put the poll up now.
Another poll.
Next outfit themed.
Next...
outfit themed.
Ummmm...
Okay.
Alt girl.
Uhhh...
What was the- Ah!
Magical girl.
Tomboy.
And then the next one- What was the last one?
Okay.
Steampunk?
Steampunk.
Okay.
Here we go.
Alright.
We'll put that for ten minutes.
This one has the privilege of having ten minutes.
This is wrong!
It's just like the- Just like the last poll, you know?
The last poll had ten minutes as well.
Guys!
I don't- I mean, the last poll also had the equal amount of time as- as the current poll.
So...
Oh my god.
Tomboy is like so fucking- It's so- It's so ahead.
I honestly am surprised.
I'm surprised because like I thought you guys would want the the other one.
But magical girl had- They're the loudest.
The old girl is like the loudest speakers in chat.
But like the quiet- The quiet majority are for tomboys.
I just found it funny.
The quiet majority right there.
Alright, Let me look at the next stretch goals.
The next one.
Let's see.
...
I think like the voice pack theme, I would do that on the community post for everybody to decide because like- That is like a lot.
That is a lot to talk about.
So the voice pack and the bento one will be done... will be done a separate in the community post.
And we'll do that another time for that.
What else?
What else do we have?
Let's see.
Does anyone know how much we made in total from the auction?
Can anyone let me know?
I need to know what goals we've hit.
I need to know what goals we're at right now.
Guys, I need my human calculators.
This is it.
This is your time to shine.
71,000.
Holy fuck.
We made 71... we're at 130k.
Okay, let me look at this right now.
130k.
Okay, 150.
We get the... we get...
My human dad will stream on his PS5.
So we've currently hit... okay, we have... okay, we've done the Twitter profile.
We've announced... we've done that, we've done that.
We've done that.
I need to keep track of everything I've done.
I can't believe I did so many things already and it's only been four hours.
We've...
Uh...
We did the hot sauce.
We did that.
I can get...
I'm so... I can get Forklift certified.
Um...
Okay.
If...
Ditto and I already talked about what song we're doing.
That one chat goes on the side, guys.
We already figured out what chat... what song we're doing.
If we hit 60k...
If we hit 60k on the Tiltify, I'll announce the song that we're doing.
I'll let you guys know.
If we hit 60k at the Tiltify, you guys will know what song we're doing.
It's just that easy.
Oh no.
$60.
What will we do?
Oh no.
I know you guys want to.
I want to know.
Aren't you guys curious?
Oh, it's like...
It's like added...
Okay, it's like...
Uh...
We actually...
We...
We're adding the auction amount.
That's why I asked for like what the...
How much we made on the auction.
Uh...
Because we're adding the auction amount to the Tiltify.
To the stretch goals for this.
So even though it says 59k...
Oh!
It's almost there!
Holy shit, it's almost there!
Oh my god, Miku!
Thank you so much for $500!
Holy shit!
Oh my god, thank you for $500!
Oh my god, thank you!
Oh!
Alright.
We are going to...
Okay, I need to...
I don't...
I need to remember what the name is called.
It's a Pokemon song!
I just...
It's a Pokemon song.
So I need to...
I need to remember the actual name.
Oh, it's 123.
After the rain.
Um...
With Ditto.
That is the song we're singing.
Um...
Apparently, I'm singing Soraru?
Is that his name?
Yeah.
I'm...
I'm not sure failure is a really good song.
Uh...
But I have two songs to cover.
But that is...
The duet cover.
That I'll be doing.
Um...
With Ditto!
There you guys go!
Now you know!
Alright, Genshin, I take a knee.
And one, two, three.
With Ditto.
Yeah.
Yeah, my two cover songs.
More money raised.
Well, to be fair, more people are using the money to bid on the auction because it's like a physical item that they can get.
Let's see.
I'm just trying to see what else can we do before we actually do stuff.
It's just been me talking as we were like for hours.
What the fuck?
Not important?
Wait, how do I get a forklift certification?
Forklift certification.
How do I do that?
Okay, forklift certification.
Everything you need to know.
What counts as a forklift?
How do I get that?
Contact us today.
Okay.
Okay, offers a training course.
Do I have to be there?
Like, I need to know.
Do I actually have to be there to get a certificate?
Well, I cannot just take a test?
Okay, forklift certification.
Test.
There must be a way where I can just pay and just get a random certificate.
In Connecticut or something.
Like, there has to be a state that would just let me...
Like, even though I'm Canadian.
I know I'm Canadian.
But there has to be a state that's corrupted enough to just let me pay to have a certificate.
That's illegal.
There has to be one state.
It's okay.
I'll only be able to legally drive a forklift.
There.
I know.
Doki, please.
Forklifting is serious business.
How dare you.
How fucking dare you.
Forklifting is serious.
Why would you illegally want it?
How fucking dare you, Doki.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Alright, guys.
Oh shit, what the fuck?
When did we get 62K?
I was talking about fucking forklifts and we got the 62K.
Oh my god.
Thank you guys.
That's crazy.
Oh my god.
Cancelled by forklift operations on Twitter.
What are you gonna do?
Cancel me because of charity?
That's fucked up.
If they cancel me, I'll just be like, you hate charity.
Yeah, what can they do after that?
They can't cancel me.
It's all about the charity.
That's fucked up.
Alright, let's see.
I'm trying to like see what's next after this.
Oh my god, we can actually do something.
Alright, guys.
We can actually play something.
We're at the point where we can...
We don't have to talk anymore, chat.
We finally hit it.
We finally...
We've reached the point where we can actually play something.
Oh my god.
We've made it.
It took us four hours.
But we made it.
Oh shit, but the pull.
Oh shit.
Okay, don't worry.
Tomboy won.
Okay.
The next one, the next official outfit will be tomboy.
The four hour ad is over.
What if we fucked up?
I made you guys watch me play supermarket simulator.
That would be pretty...
I wouldn't, guys.
I swear I would not.
I'm not gonna make you guys...
I would not make you guys watch me play supermarket simulator.
Even for charity.
That's gonna be on my schedule next week.
Do not worry.
That would be...
Do not worry, chat.
That will be its own thing.
So do not worry about that.
Anyway, actually I'm gonna check the auction real quick before we go.
Before we actually play anything.
Oh, we can...
We can play forklift.
Okay, let me...
We can do forklift.
Let's get our forklift certification on the internet.
Forklift.
Okay, we'll get our forklift certificate on the internet.
Which is the best forklift simulator?
Guys, I...
Guys, which is the best forklift simulator?
Forklift game.
On Steam.
I need to know.
Okay, best forklift operator.
No, this one says 196 reviews.
They deserve to be called...
Okay, can I get a certificate that allows you to visit three warehouses?
This game was in early access for five months?
Oh my god.
Wait, is that...
Is that an actual game?
What is this?
This is not forklift.
This is a martial artist game.
Who keeps saying...
What is this game?
I'm talking about forklift.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Okay, there is...
Okay, there is one.
We have...
There is one...
Okay, this is called best forklift operator.
Wait, is this only in VR?
No, okay.
This can be played...
This can be played on PC.
Okay, let me double check.
Warehouse forklift, forklift in box.
Alright, I'm gonna buy this.
I'm spent...
I need you guys to know.
I'm literally spending...
$25.
I'm kidding.
I'm gonna play forklift simulator.
Okay, it's not forklift simulator.
It is...
It is not forklift simulator.
It's like...
It's called...
What is it called?
Fuck, what is this called?
It's called best forklift operator.
And I will be playing...
I'm gonna play...
Pay $25 for this.
I just need to remember what my password is.
And I need to make sure I don't say it out loud.
Okay.
Yeah, remember my password real quick, guys.
Alright.
It's okay.
Thank god for password manager.
Thank god.
Alright.
Oh my god.
That would be very unfortunate if you guys had a password for that.
That would be so unfortunate.
Alright.
I'm gonna be the best forklift operator out there.
And then...
And then I'll take an actual test.
I need to know for sure if I'm good at this.
Okay, guys.
Like, I need to know for sure that this is...
That I would pass.
If I do it now...
I'll be like prepared for the actual written test.
Okay, let me down.
I need to down.
Did I not buy it?
Oh my god.
Did I forget?
I fucking forgot to buy it.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Agree and pay.
We're doing it live.
I forgot to agree to the terms of service.
So I never bought it.
I never bought it because I forgot to agree to the terms of service.
Alright.
Install content.
Nice.
It's 8 gigabyte.
Holy fuck.
Why the fuck is the forklift operator 8 gigabyte?
8 gigabytes.
What is in there?
Are they bitcoin mining?
Alright, let me go to solo gaming real fast.
Okay.
Solo gaming.
Boop.
Alright.
Here we go.
I can't believe.
Forklift simulator.
Okay.
But forklift simulator 2023 has terrible reviews.
We need to be properly trained.
We can't cheese the system.
Because when I make it...
When I said why can't I just pay to get the degree, people were like no.
Forklifting is serious business, guys.
So of course, because it's serious business, of course I will pay for the most expensive one.
Is this not what you wanted?
You guys were like, woah, you can't cheap out on this.
Woah!
Doki, we're ashamed of you for cheaping out.
Alright, here we go.
You know, watch me be the best forklift operator out there for charity.
This is my content now.
Okay, gaming.
It's not World Quest, it's forklift operator.
There's a leaderboard?
Why is there a leaderboard for this?
There's gonna be someone better than me?
Do you want to play?
Sure.
Welcome to the tutorial mode.
Before you become the best forklift operator you have to know how to steer a forklift.
Okay.
Let's learn the basis of Forklift.
Driving and... alright.
What is this?
What is square?
What is... this is mouse and keyboard.
Why is this...
No, please.
Why is this not...
Why is this not mouse and keyboard?
What is square?
Oh, okay.
Be careful and control your current progress.
Okay.
Next to...
Press to add number of crashes.
In career... in career mode on the right, you can find information about earned money.
If you need a break, just pause the game.
What is... what is lines?
What's a line?
Go straight ahead using... if you need to stop, press X.
What is X?
What... what is X?
We're forklifting, guys.
This is serious.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
Ow.
Okay.
It's okay.
I didn't hurt too much.
Alright.
Wait.
Do I need...
Do I need to drive in a straight line?
Can I just...
Oh, it doesn't matter.
I don't get penalties.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna lower... I'm gonna lower this.
How do I reverse?
I can't reverse.
My PlayStation isn't plugged in!
How do I reverse?
I can't lower it!
This is aslo...
Guys.
I don't know.
I don't think I'm gonna be the best forklift operator out there.
I have... I have a feeling.
I have... I'm getting control.
Guys.
I have a feeling.
I have a feeling this is gonna... I might as well just bribe somebody.
For charity.
If I tell him it's for charity, do you think he'll give me a certificate?
Do you think?
I'm gonna pay $25 for this.
I can't plug in my control!
There it is.
Okay.
Here we go.
Nice.
Controller plugged.
Whoa!
Oh, oh.
I'm doing it!
Oh!
Nope.
How do I drive back?
Okay.
Drive back.
No.
That's honking.
Whoa!
Where am I?
Please.
Reverse!
Oh my god.
Wait.
We're gonna figure this out.
Gamepad.
Forklift up.
Acceleration brake.
There's no reverse!
Reverse!
There's actually no...
Wait.
Is it transmission change?
Left stick button.
It has to be.
Okay.
Am I...
Am I doing it?
Please!
Reverse!
Okay.
I'm gonna restart.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna get forklift certification right here.
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
Start.
All right.
At top left side.
Next to pallet.
Number of crashes.
Use carrier mode.
Okay.
You go straight ahead.
If you need to stop, press X.
Okay.
Oh, there we go.
We're doing this.
Am I going reverse?
Okay.
Why am I not going reverse?
Why am I not...
Oh!
I'm going reverse!
I figured it out!
Guys!
It's okay.
We don't need to follow this anymore.
Okay.
Use...
We need to do that.
And then...
No.
Come on, Doki.
You got to pass that test, Doki!
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
Now reverse.
Oh.
Wait.
What?
Okay.
All right.
Now...
Now up it go!
Up it go!
Oh my God!
This forklift certification is so easy.
Why do you need a license for this?
Oh my God!
A child can do it!
Ow.
Okay.
It's okay.
It doesn't matter.
They're not that expensive anyway.
Okay.
So it's better to support the pallets.
So supported already.
Oh, okay.
We need to put this...
Okay.
We got to put it here.
All right.
And then we go forward.
Gaming.
Okay.
And then we...
Up it goes.
And then...
Oh my God!
I'm so fucked up!
Get out of this game.
Okay.
And then...
Reverse.
Wait.
Get out.
How does...
How do I let it leave?
Leave.
No, no, no, no, no.
Leave my fucking thing!
Okay.
Guys.
Oh, oh.
Leave.
Leave!
It has to fall in vain!
Oh, oh.
Eventually!
Leave!
Why isn't it...
Why isn't gravity working?
Gravity!
It wouldn't leave.
I'm reversing!
I'm stuck!
Why am I stuck?
What is stuck?
What is stu...
Oh!
Wait.
I'm out.
It worked!
I did it!
Okay, wait.
Did I do it?
Did I?
Yeah.
I missed?
What do you mean?
It's clearly on the thing!
Oh!
Does it have to be specifically a line?
This is so...
No.
Please.
PLEASE!
Please, why is it like this?!
Alright.
I think I'm ready.
I think the tutorial has taught me enough.
Honestly.
I think I'm ready for like...
I think I'm ready for level one.
I think I'm ready for the grudge.
Oh..
That's a good one.
If I successfully get $500 with only five within eight minutes, then I'm forklift certified.
I will actually take a test for forklift certification though.
I would actually do it.
But like...
But like I have to play this game first to see my potential.
Okay.
Come on.
We'll reverse.
And then...
Put it all the way down.
And then stick it in the hole.
Stick it in the hole.
Why aren't you...
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I need to align the forklift.
Okay.
In the hole you go.
There you go.
Nice.
Alright.
Where do I go now?
Guys, where was I supposed to go?
Do I just...
Do I just put it in there?
I forgot.
What was my job?
Guys, what was my job?
Do I...
Do I just put it...
I for...
What was my job?
I don't remember.
I was too busy.
Is it here?
Do I take it outside?
Oh, this wasn't the thing I was supposed to do.
Oh, wait.
This isn't even the item.
Okay.
Get off.
Nice.
No, no, no, no, no.
Fuck.
Okay.
Four more collisions.
That's okay.
This wasn't the original item.
The item's outside.
All right.
If I get one box, guys.
If I manage to succeed at putting this box up there, that's all we need.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Okay.
One more.
Where am I?
All right.
Oh.
Please.
No!
How am I supposed to feed charity?
Guys!
How am I supposed to do charity, guys?
I don't understand!
Okay.
Wait.
This is it.
I just need one item.
That's all I need.
It does not matter.
As long as I get one item.
Okay.
Okay, now reverse.
I'm gonna line this better.
It's all about one item.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh.
Down you go.
Down, down.
Okay.
Come on.
Come on, get in the hole!
I need to be forklift certified!
This is it.
Please.
No, please.
Why?
Where is it?
Where?
This has to be it.
Is it up?
Oh my god, please.
Okay, if I go down more and then... Why?
Why?
Alright.
There we go.
No.
It's underneath!
What do you all still want from me?
Okay.
I'm slowly dragging it.
Alright, then we go forward.
Wait, wait.
It's up!
Oh!
Oh my god.
I'm holding it.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
I'm trying to... I'm looking at my rear view mirror.
My rear view mirror.
Why am I not there?
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
No.
It's okay.
We haven't had any collision!
Oh-DBc!
Oh!
Alright, that's okay.
One is fine.
One collision is fine.
We're not perfect.
Alright, here we go.
And then we put it over there.
Why is there this one box blocking my way?
Get out!
Get this box out of here!
Okay.
Nice.
And then we put it here.
And then we tuck it out.
Okay.
Reverse.
I'm stuck.
Please!
Please.
Please just let me out.
Let me out.
Let me just place one.
That's all I ask.
No, no, no, no.
I just want to put one in there.
Okay.
And then...
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Please just go in the hole!
Put it down and rotate.
Are you the one...
Oh, wait, wait.
It's off.
Okay.
Alright, just leave.
Leave.
That's all.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Anyway, I think...
I think like...
I think like, judging by how good I was at this...
Um...
Uh...
Guys,
I think like, after seeing how good I was at...
At, you know, online...
I feel like online...
With the ability...
Uh...
We're so...
We're so locked in.
Honestly, like, judging by like, my hand-eye coordination...
Online with Forklift...
Like, I feel like...
I honestly feel like if I took the test right now...
I could...
I...
I could easily...
Get Forklift certified.
I am...
I am like, 100% so fucking confident...
That like...
Judging from like, the simulation...
There is...
No way I could fail the test.
Like, I feel like...
I felt like I was a fucking prodigy.
I...
I don't know about you...
But I felt like a fucking prodigy.
Hehehehehehe...
Sorry, I did not eat some chicken.
I had to...
If not because of the Forklift...
That I stress ate, guys...
Guys...
Just want you guys to know...
I was not stress eating...
Because of the Forklift...
Hehehehehe...
I was just...
I was just very hungry.
Okay, it has no correlation.
Guys, there was no correlation...
Between me eating the chicken...
Hehehehehe...
And...
And operating the Forklift.
No correlation at all.
I feel like...
I feel like I can...
I can do it.
I feel like...
After...
Seeing my progress...
And operating that...
It's not that difficult.
It's like driving a car.
Which I haven't drove in like 10 years.
But it's like...
It's like driving a car.
Hehehehehehe...
I haven't touched a car in 10 years.
Like, you know...
Behind the driver's seat.
But I'm pretty sure...
It's like riding a bicycle.
Which I also haven't ridden...
In 20 years.
But...
It's like walking.
Hehehehehehe...
So, handling a Forklift...
It's almost as an equivalent...
To walking.
I can feel it.
Honestly, it's gonna be so fucking easy.
It's gonna be so easy.
Hehehehehe...
There's nothing to worry about.
There's absolutely nothing to worry about.
I don't know why you guys are...
Are freaking out right now.
Hehehehehe...
Hehehehehehe...
Is sooo simple.
Hehehehehe...
Let's check on the auction real quick.
Guys, please don't judge me here.
This is a judge-free zone.
This is absolutely a judge-free zone.
Right now.
So it's pretty fucked up if you're judging me.
Hehehehehehehe.
Hehehehehe...
Hehehehehehe...
Please, please stop judging.
Oh my gosh, alright.
Where was I?
Okay.
Okay, I actually...
I actually was planning on doing the stream for another hour.
So, I will let you guys pick what you want to do for the last hour.
Because my stream stamina is going down now.
So, this time...
I'm not doing the forklift thing again because I know I'm a prodigy.
I know I'm a prodigy right now.
I could do a custom server for you guys in Apex if that's what you guys really want.
Is that what you guys want?
You guys want a custom server?
We'll do one regular game.
And one regular game.
And one...
And one fun game.
I think... I don't know what a fun game would be.
The melee.
The melee one has always been so fun.
I fucking love the melee.
Alright guys, we'll do two games of Apex, guys.
We'll do two games of Apex.
Let me swap over... Let me boot up Apex real fast.
Apex time!
It's Apex!
Apex!
Alright.
Apex time!
I haven't played Apex in a while.
I don't remember.
When did I last touch Apex?
Alright.
Okay, we gotta turn down the volume though.
Whoa!
Alright.
Apex.
Apex leggings.
Alright, let's see.
This one.
The first game will be serious.
Okay, create a match.
Alright, you guys ready?
I'm gonna... You guys have to type the... Oh wait, I was gonna say you guys won't be able to see the code.
Because every...
All my overlays covering up!
All the overlays are covering up the fucking game.
I don't even know the code.
Alright, 3, 2, 1!
Boop!
Here's the code.
So you remember to...
You remember to turn... This time I actually will turn off the audio because I don't trust you guys!
I don't trust you guys so I made sure that...
Aiden!
You think you can... You have the privilege?
I can...
Get all the top donors and then...
No, that would be so fucked up!
I mean like...
You think I let you on my team?
You're not top 5 donors!
I won't do that.
That's so fucked up for me to do!
That's so fucked up!
Guys, I'm not...
Guys, guys, it was a joke.
It was... I swear it was a joke guys.
It was a joke.
I mean...
Alright.
I will do two games.
We'll do two games.
This is why the system is the way it was!
Wait, you're both controller!
Wait, okay.
I forgot I can analyze the situation!
Oh shit, Cameron!
Oh my god!
I'm just scouting, guys.
I'm just...
I'm scouting!
I'm just scouting the scenario!
Guys!
I'm just trying to scout out...
Like, what?
What?
What did I do?
What did I do, chat?
I don't understand.
What?
What did I do?
I was just analyzing!
Oh, is analyzing wrong now?
When was that illegal, chat?
When was that illegal to do?
I don't know what you're talking about.
Alright, let's see.
I'm gonna help put you guys in teams real fast.
Alright, we have...
We have a few more spaces left.
We have...
Oh, okay.
Let's put you guys in here.
We have two more spaces.
We have one space left, chat.
Oh!
Oh, one more space.
And then...
Alright!
This will be a regular game.
We'll do World's Edge, because it's my favorite.
Namus, Murad, Av, Amos' self-assigned team, Allao, All, Battle Royale trios, Gunrun, Team Deathmatch...
Okay, yes.
Alright.
Alright, guys.
Here we go.
We're gonna start a match in three, two, one.
I don't remember how to play.
I don't even know what's meta.
Wait, no, I do!
It's Bloodhound!
Wait, is it Bloodhound?
It's like Caustic some shit.
It's like Bloodhound.
Oh, wait.
Here.
You're so lucky.
I stopped for you.
Alright.
This is it.
I'm sorry I didn't have a lot of stream stamina.
Really, the whole thing I really wanted to focus on was the auction itself.
Like, a lot of the energy was put on organizing the auction.
But I still hope you guys enjoyed the stream so far.
Of just like, hanging out, talking, knowing about...
Oh, shit.
Uh, fuck.
I heard Caustic was meta now.
Where's Bloodhound meta?
I don't remember.
Doki, we have no teammate.
Well...
Sucks to be you.
I'm working on...
What do you want me to do?
You know you're doing...
Alright, guys.
Jumper kick.
Cameron, I swear to god.
If you do not be jumpmaster...
If you do not be jump...
If you...
None of you guys be jumpmaster, I will end this game right now.
I will stop this game right now.
If none of you jump.
I was swapped you away from my team.
I will fucking find another masters player.
I can analyze again.
I look how I've jumped fucking emotes now.
Typical Doki.
What do you mean?
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm just saying.
I didn't mean I would do it now.
Alright.
We're fine.
Everything will be fine.
If you guys didn't know.
If you see like a...
If you see like a crow near you.
It means there's no one near you.
Crows usually are meant for like people far away.
But they know where the general direction is.
They're just not close by.
So like I'm not too worried about that.
R9 fucking sucks though.
Fuck man.
I wish the R9 is better.
Those poor teammates.
They should be honored!
What do you mean?
Alright.
I don't wanna...
Okay.
We can...
We need like better armor.
Wait.
Do we have anybody that can scan?
Oh wait.
What?
Okay.
Who the fuck is over there right now?
What are you doing?
Huh?
Did he accidentally land in the wrong area?
Bro.
Wait.
He's solo!
Go Cameron!
Go!
Cameron don't be a little pussy!
You're masters!
You're console masters.
Play your part.
Okay.
I didn't see him.
I did not see him.
Look.
I didn't die though.
So...
Okay.
This teammate is coming over.
Guys.
This teammate is coming.
No!
He's one!
He's literally one!
Guys.
I swear to God.
He's literally...
Guys!
I swear to God!
He's literally one!
Oh you fuck.
Oh my God.
Guys.
Please.
Thirst him.
Please thirst him for me.
Okay.
Alright.
We're okay.
Everything is fine.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Everything is fine.
There's nothing to worry about.
Where is the guy we...
Oh what the fuck?
Okay.
Maybe not that fine now.
Wait.
Where is the guy we thirsted?
Did we not thirst him?
Did we not...
Okay.
Why is there so many people on us?
Alright.
I don't wanna...
I don't feel so good here.
Where's the vantage?
Where the fuck is the vantage?
He's over here.
Okay.
I'm gonna scan.
We scan.
He can't vantage all of us.
Guys.
You have to remember.
He can't vantage all of us.
There we go.
Okay.
Are you guys ready?
We go in together.
Go.
There's no way he can vantage all of us.
I'm a firm believer of that.
There's no way.
That's right.
That's fucking right.
Run you little bitch!
You run you little coward.
I have all... I'm faster than you.
What the fuck are you doing though?
Please.
Okay.
I couldn't hit the fucking last shot.
I knew.
I knew you couldn't run forever.
Okay.
Why are we even charged?
That's good.
Look.
I haven't used the...
Guys.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
It's okay.
I have to heal here.
We're fine.
We're okay.
We are okay.
We're in zone.
Alright.
This is fine.
This is so fine.
You're on the high ground.
That would be so fucking cool if I landed that.
I got it.
If only.
My champion.
Oh!
Don't die.
Okay.
There are three men chilling down there.
Res.
I'll cover.
I can cover this.
Go high ground.
Say high ground.
They're coming down the stairs.
They're right down the stairs.
Oh my god.
Please.
For the love of god.
Okay.
Alright.
That's fine.
Literally one guy left.
Wait.
Where is he?
Where the fuck?
Where did he get shot?
Where?
What?
Where did you guys get shot?
He might be behind us.
I cannot res, guys.
I don't know where he is.
And that's why I'm scared.
I don't know where he is, guys.
No hostile?
Where the fuck is he?
Wait.
They res'd.
Oh my god.
Okay.
They're like back there.
Alright, guys.
Guys, we have to camp these bodies so they get nothing.
That is our goal.
We gotta make sure they don't get anything.
Heal!
You're so low!
Here, take this phoenix kit!
Here!
Oh.
Wait, he's here.
That's a whole team.
Wait, that's a different team.
Wait a minute.
This is... do we have... okay.
I'm gonna do something extreme.
Um...
Guys.
Okay, guys.
Guys, I'm leaving.
Goodbye.
Guys, I'm...
Goodbye!
Guys, take the zip!
It's the only way!
I swear.
It's the only way.
You have to take the zip.
Just don't die.
Okay, we leave.
Come over here!
Dude, leave!
There's so many people!
Come on!
Guys, we have to go!
We have to go to the zone!
I can't babysit you forever!
Okay, there's people to my left.
Okay, we're gonna... oh, there's people behind me.
Guys, we just leave.
Just head to the fucking zone.
Who cares?
We just need to go to the zone.
Just run.
That's all I care.
It's okay.
We're fine.
We're so healthy.
Wait, there's a package.
No, that's my crow.
Never mind.
Okay, we take the zip, guys!
Guys!
We take a zip!
And then we leave!
Again!
There's nobody near me because I scanned a crow.
We go here!
There should be nobody there, right?
Alright.
Guys, I'm so fucking hopeful for us.
Whoa!
Okay, I'm so fucking hopeful.
What the fuck?
No!
My package!
Fuck!
Okay, my package.
Okay, we're in center zone.
We're center zone.
There's nothing that could go wrong.
Except for these guys who might get like...
Kraber or some shit.
So I don't... I'm actually a little scared.
We might get Krabered.
Alright.
It's okay!
We're top 10!
That's so good for us.
It's okay!
Wait a minute.
I hear something.
I gotta make sure.
I gotta make sure there's nobody behind me.
Please.
They're fighting!
They're fighting over here!
Does anyone have a sniper?
I can barely see what's going on!
Alright, it's fine.
I wanna thirst this guy, but he's so fucking far.
God damn it.
I'm so close to thirsting him.
No, he's so close.
I can't hit your shot.
Oh.
You know what?
Good for you.
I'm glad you hit your shot.
I'm happy for you.
Alright.
Alright, we're good.
Okay, we're in zone.
We're in zone.
Nothing to worry about.
Okay, I gotta grab that.
I'm gonna make sure there's nobody behind us too.
That's what I'm worried about.
I need to make sure my backs are free.
From anybody that wants to third us.
I'll take the redeploy.
Where's the redeploy?
There's people to my right.
Oh my god, he was flesh!
That guy was fucking flesh!
We're in zone.
We don't have to worry.
Wait, what?
Okay, let me bat real fast.
No, it's fine!
It's okay!
We're so healthy!
We're so healthy right now.
It's fine.
Nothing to worry about.
I need energy.
Do you guys have energy?
Oh my god we're all running with energy.
Why are we all running energy?
Guys that was not very smart of us.
Wait, what?
Where?
There.
Too hostile.
Above, above, above, above, above, above!
Above us, above us!
Above us.
We got a wall.
Okay, they're right above us.
Put walls!
Cameron!
Use your master skills and put up walls!
Wait, what?
What?
Wait, did they put up the redeploy?
Oh, we're not there.
Guys, we can steal their redeploy.
Guys!
We steal their redeploy!
Come, come, come, come, come!
It's ours now!
Umm...
We have to go this way.
Guys, guys, guys!
Come here, come here, come here!
Come here!
We go in the tunnel!
Fight this, fight this!
Okay, we're fine, we're fine, we're so f**ing fine.
We're so healthy.
Wait, did they win this already?
No, I don't have nades.
I don't have nades.
I can't do anything.
I can't do anything about it.
And this time there's no nades!
I can't do anything about it!
I don't have nades!
Break the door!
Break the door with your Rampart Art!
Trust me!
You have Rampart Art!
Break it!
It's okay.
Never mind then.
Alright, nice.
I can't see jack shit, but okay.
I'm gonna heal now.
I can't see anything.
Alright!
We're getting ulted.
Guys, come back to me!
Come back to me!
Guys, I don't wanna do this anymore!
We go in the tunnel.
Trust me!
We go in the tunnel!
Trust!
Come back!
Come back, Wraith!
Don't be a hero!
I'm gonna thirst him though.
Wraith, no!
Don't be a hero!
Okay, he's fucked.
We can't save him.
Like, there's no way.
There's no way we can save this man.
There's no way.
I'm gonna Q.
I'm gonna give you a Q in three seconds.
There is... on the roof?
We can kill him on the roof actually.
Yeah, knock one guy.
Yeah.
Nice.
Oh, dead!
Dead, dead, dead!
Full dead!
I picked him up!
Go rez!
Go rez him!
They're all dead!
Go rez!
Go rez him!
They're all dead!
We have rez!
Go be a hero!
Rez this man!
Which I'll take then.
I'll take this actually.
Okay, don't be a hero maybe.
Maybe don't be a hero.
I only have five energy ammo.
Oh, wait.
Nice.
Are you rezzing him?
Oh, shit.
Yeah, do not rez him yet.
There's people here.
You're free!
You're free to rez!
Trust me!
No one will know!
Cameron, be a hero!
Trust me!
Cameron, trust me!
No one will know!
I swear to god, no one will know!
See, I told you!
They didn't know!
I'm leaving.
Holy shit.
I told you!
No one knew!
You needed to trust me!
I told you no one will know!
Go grab the fucking...
He's flash.
I told you guys no one will know.
Like, it was so easy.
Nice.
I'm gonna bat.
Oh no.
Okay, we don't have any rez beacons here, guys.
No one will know.
Okay.
Let's see.
SIDE!
I got there!
I did it so hard!
No!
That's right, bitch!
You deserve it!
Get thirsty!
I got shot in the side!
No!
I did so much!
What happened, Cameron?
Did you not plug in your controller?
I analyzed you!
Cameron!
GG!
I analyzed you, Cameron!
Cameron, give me your excuse right now what happened.
I need to know.
Cameron.
Tape and chat.
What is your excuse in chat?
No stream delay.
Yeah, let me put a stream delay on this.
You confused me.
I got sniped!
Someone please kill this man.
He's literally solo.
He's literally solo!
Run at him!
He has nothing!
Just beat him up with your fist!
He's solo!
Oh my god!
Punch him!
Cameron for goal.
He for goal.
GG's.
GG's guys.
GG's everybody.
Alright, we will do one more game.
We will do one last game.
But like this time.
This time it will be melee only.
You cannot use any damaging abilities.
Guys, okay I'm gonna leave custom match.
And then I'm gonna create private match.
Create.
It's the same.
Is this the same code?
Okay.
Alright.
No damaging abilities.
Guys.
Melee only.
No damaging abilities.
And you can punch people.
This calls for Olympus.
Because I want the car.
I want the car.
Alright.
I don't have to analyze anybody here.
I don't have to analyze anyone.
Alright.
Okay.
No damaging abilities.
Melee only.
Chat.
Okay?
Melee only.
Let me put you guys into teams real quick.
Boop.
And then boop.
And...
I'll put you guys in observers.
Alright.
Remember.
Melee only.
No damaging abilities.
Okay?
We gotta get a car.
Guys, we gotta get a car.
Guys, we have to get a car.
We can't let them...
We gotta get a car, guys.
Team.
We gotta get a car, team.
No.
Yes, cars.
Guys, I'm literally the host.
You can't say no cars.
I'm literally the host right now.
Chat.
You can't say that to me.
You can't say that.
I'm literally the host.
Okay.
1v3?
No.
Guys.
Okay.
Fuck.
What would be a good no damaging ability?
What would be a good one?
Octane!
I can self heal.
Wait.
Okay.
Guys.
Yes.
Newcastle.
That's a good idea.
Just keep rezzing me.
We can't die.
We can't.
If you both keep rezzing me.
Oh my god!
We should have played Horizon!
Guys.
Just.
Do not.
Just keep rezzing me and then we can win this.
Alright?
We gotta think this.
We gotta.
We gotta be able to think this strategically.
Okay.
Where's.
Guys.
The car.
Right here.
We gotta get that car.
Guys.
Our only mission right now is to grab the car.
That's all we need!
We need the car!
Alright.
Where's the car?
Oh.
Here.
I fucking couldn't find the car for some reason.
Alright.
We go.
Grab the car.
Get over here!
Oh my god.
What the fuck.
I like stalled for.
Oh my god.
Did I got like grift or something?
Guys.
Okay.
I forgot we could have played Pathfinder 2.
It's okay.
We're good.
Nice.
Alright.
We got everything.
Now I don't know what the plan is anymore.
Alright.
Guys.
That was the extent of my plan.
Now I don't.
I guess we loot for heals.
Wait.
They have cars too!
What?
Alright.
Guys.
Go loot heals.
Go loot some heals right now.
Loot heals.
We need heals.
Guys.
Go do your thing.
There's no plan B.
There's another car.
Okay.
I'm gonna take you guys to the second car.
Alright.
One guy loot heals here and then we'll pick you up later.
Newcastle.
Come here.
Plan B.
Get another car.
Wait.
Loot this.
Lifeline.
Click this right now.
Lifeline is right here.
Lifeline.
Click this.
Yeah.
Oh shit.
We gotta go.
We gotta get the second car.
Who got the second car?
We gotta get the third car.
It's all the way over there.
But it's okay.
We can do this.
We can make it.
We can grab...
We can grab the third car.
It's possible.
Okay.
How do we intercept you?
We gotta go from here.
Okay.
We gotta grab that third car.
It's okay.
A little zone damage wouldn't hurt anybody.
We'll be fine.
Plan B.
Step number two.
Two cars.
Step number... Who grabbed this car?
Who keeps grabbing the cars?
Wait.
I actually got off.
Guys.
Sorry.
Get back out.
It was an accident.
Oh wait.
We need that.
Actually.
Grab that.
Grab the yellow thing.
Yeah.
Don't worry.
There's still another car here.
Grab this.
Alright.
Newcastle.
Yes.
Blue armor.
Alright.
We gotta get that car.
Wait.
What do I need?
What is this?
Oh wait.
Nice.
Alright.
Number two.
There's still...
There's still that car.
The car is still there.
You can't get that car.
We get that car first.
Wait.
Where is it?
It's still there.
Alright.
Who's gonna get...
Who has a driver's license?
Guys.
Nice.
Alright.
Now we grab the yellow things.
There has to be another yellow.
Alright.
We grab this.
This.
Step three.
Boost our armor.
It's forklift certified.
Okay.
I'll grab it.
Step three.
We split up.
We split up and grab the yellow boxes until we're...
Until we're red armor.
I go for this.
Oh my god.
This is like the most ingenious plan.
We're totally gonna...
Guys.
We split up.
You don't have to follow me anymore.
We split up and grab until we're red armor.
Guys.
This is our ingenious plan.
What the f...
How did... What?
Was there a jump pad there?
Wait.
How do we get that?
Where the f is the yellow box here?
Is it underneath?
Oh no.
There's a melee guy here.
Waaaaaah.
Okay.
I can't be here guys.
Step three failed.
I need to find another yellow box.
Oh here.
It's okay.
It didn't work.
Look.
I didn't account for them not allowing cars.
Okay.
I didn't account for that.
Instructions were a little bit unclear there.
That there was like you know.
Another car.
Like another team.
And it doesn't allow cars.
I'm gonna go for that one.
Alright.
Here we go.
Nice.
We're close to purple.
We can do this.
We can get red so easy.
Alright.
We're good for that one.
There's no way somebody will steal my car.
There's no f-ing way.
I swear to god.
If someone like drops down from high ground and just yoinks my car.
I swear to f-ing god.
That would be so f-ed up.
I'll go grab this one.
Don't worry.
I got this.
Step five.
Titch car.
No no no no no.
Cars are forever.
Wait I can scan this.
A car has a bu- Okay we can't use that.
Where is it?
Guys can we like work?
Why can't we be friends?
Cool.
Thanks guys.
It's like...
I'm just like...
Okay guys.
This is so f-ing...
Okay.
The drive through.
Alright.
We have all the yellow stuff.
Okay.
There's one hole right here.
I'm just figuring out how to get there.
He's just like hey.
You also getting those yellow things?
Yeah.
Actual.
Actual paid actor.
Oh my god look at them.
Is this also a taxi ride or?
Okay.
That poor team that's getting punched up.
Are we all going for this one too?
Hey guys.
Are we all- I'm part of your team too.
Hey guys are you also trying to get that?
Don't worry.
I'll wait for you guys too.
You guys go first.
You guys go- You first guys.
You guys- Wait what are you doing?
What are you doing?
What are you guys doing?
Are you guys- Are you guys gonna let me pick that up?
Hey I wanna pick that up too.
Come on.
You guys had your turn.
Come on guys.
Come on.
You guys had your turn.
It's my turn now.
Alright nice.
Nice.
Peace and love.
Look at that.
Oh wait.
Whoops wrong one.
That's so sweet of them to like take turns.
I really- I really appreciate it.
My mom said it's my turn for red shields.
I really do appreciate that.
That they were willing to- Uh.
That we- That we took turns there.
It's really nice.
I'm glad- I'm glad we could all work together.
And uh- Take our turn grabbing- Grabbing those red armors.
It's really nice and appreciated.
Alright.
Woop.
Alright we're in zone.
We're in zone.
The very peaceful- fight.
Well I mean it's not that peaceful.
Wait.
Oh no.
It's not that peaceful.
There's like three teams already died.
Chat.
Three teams- Wait did they lose the car?
What happened?
What the fuck happened?
Did they lose the car?
What do you mean oops?
What happened?
I swear if I come back and there's no cars.
What happened guys?
What about?
Guys!
We worked so hard to get those cars!
I kept- Guys!
What happened?
Alright punch them.
You guys can punch them when you're in the car.
Melee!
Punch them!
Punch them back!
Come on!
That's what you're right.
You can do it!
It's like Beyblade.
Come on.
Punch them!
It's one guy!
Okay wait.
First let me get closer.
Guys it's one guy.
You guys can do this.
Guys.
Please.
Okay I'm sorry.
I'm struggling too.
Guys.
Oh shit!
Red armor!
We got this!
We're so fucking ready.
We're so ready.
Alright they can't drive away forever.
Okay.
Punch them.
Yeah!
Get him!
Let him rip!
Come on.
You can't run away forever.
Just keep meleeing!
You got this!
Yes melee these guys!
Yes!
Woohoo!
It's okay.
We can Beyblade this.
Look at these fucking cars.
So stupid.
What episode of Beyblade is this?
Let him rip!
It's like Beyblade and Sonic.
Come on.
It's literally one guy!
You can do this!
You can do this team!
Just keep meleeing!
They can't run!
Oh my god.
Yes!
Here!
This is it!
Keep punching!
It's like he's one guy.
There's no way.
There's no way he can fuck around.
Get over here.
Get your ass over here.
Wait.
Melee this guy.
Woohoo!
It's okay.
I hope you guys are fucking... I hope you guys are fucking punching.
We're almost to the end.
Who scanned?
Why do you need to scan?
We're in melee only.
Don't worry.
We're red armor.
None of them have red armor like us.
None of them are as good as us guys.
Look at all these cars.
Oh yes!
Yes!
That's it!
Keep punching!
Yes!
Good.
Never stop punching!
Never stop!
Just keep going.
We can heal ourselves here too.
Are you guys punching?
I hope you guys are punching.
Why did you get off?
Why did you guys get off?
We were doing so well.
We were getting free heals.
Guys, I hope you guys are punching.
I hope.
Don't worry.
We're getting free heals right now.
No shit!
I can't shit!
Don't worry.
Come back in here.
Heal, heal.
You guys go heal yourself.
Go heal!
You need to shield yourself.
Alright, nice.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
Who made a fucking hut here?
Okay, this is our new home.
Here we go.
Nobody can hit us here.
Go heal.
Wait, I need to heal.
Alright guys, I'm gonna heal real fast.
Stay on the ship!
Stay on here so nobody can steal it!
It's okay!
We can't let anybody steal it!
It's fine.
Nobody can reach the top.
Nobody can reach the rock.
We're safe.
We're so safe.
Nobody can reach it.
It's our base defense!
We're gonna surf real fast.
Okay, you gotta...
You gotta drive us closer now.
Alright, my turn to melee.
Mom said it's my turn.
Don't worry.
We need to be on the ring.
We need to be in the ring!
We need to be in the ring, guys!
Guys!
Please.
We need to be in the ring.
Don't worry, we're almost there.
Alright, this is gonna be fine.
I feel safe.
I feel very safe.
Wait.
Wait, who's punching us?
It's okay, I feel very safe still.
I have zero shields, by the way, guys.
Wait, wait, I'm gonna craft shields.
I'm gonna craft shields.
Don't get off the car.
It's okay, they can't punch me.
We're fine.
Wait, who got off the car?
Okay, nice, nice.
We're fine.
Look at all these cars.
I'm gonna get off the car.
You guys stay in the car.
I'm gonna do something crazy.
We'll be fine.
This is our defense.
If we can...
Okay, we can literally...
This is our defense.
Weee!
You can't hurt us, we're in the air.
Yayyyyy.
Yayyyyyyy.
Yippee.
A little bouncy castle of defense.
YAYYYYY.
This is the thing... this is what devs wanted!
This is what devs wanted.
This is the true purpose of APEC Legends.
Right here.
Peak APEC Gaming.
Okay, guys, guys.
I'm gonna get off the car.
Make sure the car is safe.
I think I have another... I think I have another... I have another ult.
Okay, 89.
Nevermind.
CAR!
Woo!
Shit!
Guys, someone else drive.
Someone else drive.
Okay.
I need to know my ult.
Okay, guys, guys.
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna give ourselves another one.
Right here.
There we go.
Safe.
Wait, where is my car?
Where is my... Yes!
Where is my car?
Dude, where is my car?
Okay, here we go.
Another safe.
Yay!
We're... we're okay.
We have another defense here.
Our turret... No, no, no, no.
Do not drive in the ring.
No!
It's okay.
We're okay.
Everything is fine.
Use the bouncy castle!
Swap... swap drivers.
Swap drivers.
Guys, swap drivers.
I'm a better driver.
Swap drivers.
Okay.
Where's my car?
Where's... where is the car?
Wait, this works!
Stay there!
Just stay there!
You'll be safe!
Do not move!
You'll be so safe!
Just do not move!
Okay.
Never mind.
It stopped working.
We almost had it.
We almost had it there.
We almost got it.
What could have been?
Just stay in the car!
Just stay in the car and keep bouncing!
You got this!
Just stay there forever!
Oh, shit.
I thought you... you technically like...
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright.
Whoa!
Shit!
Okay.
I'm gonna...
Boom.
Alright.
There you go.
Yeah.
I have only have one bat.
I only have one bat here.
Okay, as long as I am in the air, nothing can hurt me.
As long as I am in the...
Wait.
My car.
Okay.
Alright.
Here you go.
As long as I am in the air, no one can hurt me.
This is the launch if we are going...
No!
Close!
It's deep!
Oh, god.
Oh,
god.
Oh my god!
Okay.
I'm fine.
I'm...
Oh my god.
Everything is fine.
EVERYTHING IS FINE!
Everything is...
Everything is okay.
Every...
Everything will be okay.
Everything will be...
I told you guys.
Having...
The moment we had so many...
I knew it was gonna be clutch.
I fucking knew.
I fucking knew it was gonna be clutch right there.
I knew it was gonna work out.
Having a two... The shield back.
The shield back.
If I keep shielding.
No!
Go!
Holy shit!
I'm just sitting up here.
They can't melee me if I'm on top of it!
No!
Ah!
Fuck!
Just heal.
No!
We were so close.
Oh my god.
Who the fuck won?
Is this the mosh pit?
Who fucking won?
Oh!
He has Doki in the name!
That... Technically that means me!
Chat.
He has Doki in the name.
That's technically me.
Dude.
I'm in there.
We take those.
We fucking take those.
GG.
Hahaha.
Holy shit.
I fucking love melee only.
Melee only is always...
It's always fucking chaotic as hell.
Oh my god.
We take those.
Guys.
GG's everybody.
We fucking take those.
Hahaha.
Jesus Christ.
Holy fuck.
Alright.
Let's do an auction check.
An auction check guys.
How many have we...
How many... How much have we made so far in the auction?
Guys.
Any... My human calculators.
Rise up!
Is your chance to shine.
Human calculators.
Bacon!
Thank you so much for the 50 gifted chips!
Thank you.
Thank you!
Oh my god.
Thank you so much!
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you!
I can't believe...
How much we've made...
How much support we got...
On the charity itself.
It really blows my mind.
$72,000.
Oh!
Oh my god.
That is actually insane.
Guys.
Thank you guys so much.
I can't believe...
How we raised...
So much.
We made like...
$140,000.
That's actually...
Um...
Crazy.
Guys.
All I'm saying...
Is if we get...
10k...
If we manage to get...
Uh...
10 more thousand dollars...
We can have...
My dad... Human dad...
By the way... Stream on his PS5 for you.
That's what I'm saying.
And with only 10k...
Hahaha.
We are almost there.
Alright.
Let me...
Actually let me do the calculation real quick.
Just to be sure.
Yes.
The...
Father stream.
The father stream.
Guys.
Alright.
I'll give you guys a choice.
It's either... Okay.
Guys.
You know what?
I'll even throw...
In an extra.
I'll even do...
The Pokemon Smasher Pass.
If you guys get there.
I know it's a...
200k goal.
But...
I'll even do...
The Pokemon Smasher Pass.
Hahaha.
If you guys get to 10k...
If you guys get to 150k...
Um... We are currently...
At 140k.
So we...
Need... Uh...
78,000...
To have both Pokemon...
Smasher Pass.
And...
The dad stream.
The Doki dad stream.
Uh...
Why not...
No.
Don't do this to...
The power.
Power.
But it has been...
Crazy though.
I think we raised in total...
Almost 200k dollars though.
Uh... We include the...
Uh...
No Visage though.
Thank fucking god.
Hahaha.
Um... I'm so happy...
We didn't get Visage.
Thank goodness.
Hahaha.
All
I'm saying...
All I'm saying...
Is that if I have...
Any... Billion...
Any billionaire's son or daughter...
Right now...
I'm gonna...
Reminding that we originally said...
200k for Visage.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
You know what?
You know what guys?
Okay.
I'm gonna throw you a bone.
I'm gonna throw you... Because I feel so nice right now.
I'm gonna throw you guys a bone.
Chat.
Because...
I feel incredibly generous.
If...
We hit...
On the Tiltify...
If we hit...
78...
Thousand...
I will play one chapter of Visage.
I'll do one chapter of the Visage.
And...
The Pokemon Smasher Pass.
We're gonna take away the human...
My dad playing on his PS5.
Streaming on his PS5.
I'm gonna substitute.
I will substitute...
For... playing...
Visage.
One chapter.
If we hit...
On the Tiltify...
On the... On the stretch goal.
78...
Okay, okay.
I'll give you... Alright!
I'll give you three!
Alright!
I feel incredibly generous...
Right now.
We don't want you...
Doki!
We want your...
Father!
Both... Both are gay!
How dare you take... Okay!
Alright!
If we hit...
78...
Thousand...
You get...
Pokemon Smasher Pass...
The Dad PS5 Stream...
And... Visage...
One chapter.
That's all I'll give you.
Hahahaha!
Look...
I don't think... Cause like someone's like...
100k on Tiltify...
For the full game...
Look!
I'll entertain you guys!
I'll even entertain you with this!
If you manage...
To get... 100k...
On Tiltify...
Umm...
Before the stream is over... I'll give you guys...
30 more minutes.
Hahahaha!
I'll give you guys...
30 more minutes...
If you manage to hit...
100k...
On the Tiltify itself...
You get the full game.
This does not include the auction.
By the way.
Hahahaha!
Not enough time, unfortunately.
What are you?
A quitter?
Hahahaha!
How is this?
That is not a scam.
I literally went from 400k...
To 100k.
Guys...
I literally went from...
400k to a...
That is like the most...
Bargain you could ever get.
That is like 70% off.
For my own sanity.
And I'm giving you 30 minutes...
To reach that.
To be fair...
Yeah!
It went down...
From 400k.
400k was a scam to be...
But it didn't turn into a scam in the end!
Because I lowered it down to 100k!
Hahahaha!
But this...
Does not include...
The auction.
This does not include the auction.
You have to...
The moment...
Look, I'll even be more generous.
Fine.
Guys, never say I was not nice.
Hahahaha!
Never say I was not generous.
But I'll even give you until...
My OBS hits 6 hours.
Until my...
The moment...
My OBS hits 6 hours.
Which is...
Um...
Hahahaha!
Which is...
Which is like...
Okay, let me count.
Which is in 40...
I'm giving you 40 minutes, guys.
I'm literally giving you...
40 minutes...
To hit that.
Guys, I'm gonna...
It's not fake Jitter Rob!
I literally gave you a 10 minute extension!
What do you mean?
I...
Alright, you guys debate amongst yourself.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
It's been...
It's been fucking 5 hours.
I have not had a bathroom break.
I'm gonna be right back, chat.
Alright.
Yeah, I don't think we're gonna be hitting that 100k.
Hahahaha!
I like how someone's still trying to bargain.
It was like, what about...
5 dollars?
Guys, I was very...
Perfectly clear...
On how this is gonna go.
I don't listen perfectly.
Let it be 80...
Okay, okay.
90k.
Final offer.
It is 5...
I cannot say it's a scam.
I literally went down from 400k.
Hahahaha!
Alright.
Final offer.
You're not... you're not like...
Weathering me down.
Like, I know what you guys are trying to do.
You guys are trying to like, weather me down...
More and more...
Until like, I get to the number you want.
Like, you're trying...
Don't think I don't know what you're doing right now.
Don't think I don't know.
90k!
That is...
Absolutely...
My final offer.
I will not go below that.
There is no way.
We've done it before.
It's called haggling.
Yes!
Haggling's over!
You have...
30... 40...
35 minutes.
You have...
To hit 90k.
And with that 90k...
I...
Will fully play Visage.
This is...
This is for charity.
There's no haggling.
Hahahaha!
Guys!
Look, you have to be reasonable guys.
You have to be reasonable about my...
Mental health.
For the...
For the brain and behavior foundation.
Hahahaha!
Look, I did say...
I did say...
Seven...
78...
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
We jumped $6000!
Holy...
Guys...
Uh...
Guys, we're like...
Keep talking to Doki.
She adds more perks guys.
She's desperate.
Guys, keep talking.
The more we weather her down, the more she'll give us.
The more everything is attainable now guys.
We have to keep weathering her down.
She's gonna give up eventually.
If everyone just donates.
Keep stalling.
Guys, stop figuring us out.
Guys, no more!
I will not be giving any more perks.
I will not be getting... no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You're not getting any more perks from me, chat.
We've established...
We have established 90k.
That is the lowest I will go.
That is the lowest you will bargain with me.
I'm literally Asian.
You can't out-haggle me.
There is in no possible way you can out-haggle me.
I'm literally Asian.
I lived in Asia.
I had to haggle for real there.
But only if you get to 90k will I fully play Visage.
What?
Oh my god, we're almost there!
Dragoons!
1k more!
And you get the first chapter of Visage.
You get the first chapter of Visage.
And one more K and then you get first chapter.
You should be proud of it.
But honestly, Dragoons, you guys should be proud of yourself to raise this much money for 2k.
You should be proud of yourself to raise this much money for 2k.
It's actually insane how much you guys all worked together for such a great cause.
You know what?
Alright, hey guys.
Guys.
Okay, wait.
Let me see.
Guys, I'll give you guys... You know what?
You know what, guys?
Don't worry.
Let's see.
10k.
No!
What do you mean?
Oh my god.
I just sent in 10 dollars.
For my own charity.
I just put in 10 dollars.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm gonna help out.
She shows weakness.
Now is our time.
No!
This is not weakness!
I am helping you guys out.
Do not take this as weakness.
Do not take this as weakness, guys.
Alright.
Okay.
For charity.
I'm doing my part.
Boop.
I'll give you guys the first chapter of Visage.
I'm doing my part.
You're welcome.
I did it for you guys.
I gave you the first chapter of Visage right there.
I added an extra zero.
I could have been 10!
I never said what chapter it was.
A tutorial level is technically a chapter.
I'm just saying.
If you think about it...
Hmm...
Scam.
No!
The scam!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
I will do one chapter.
I'll do 30 more minutes.
Tic-Tac!
30 more minutes!
Alright.
Since...
Alright, guys...
We are at...
We got the...
Okay, I'm not gonna do Pokmon.
I need to be like...
Hanging in the mines.
I feel like I need a drink for that.
I feel like...
Guys, I'm sorry.
I feel like I need a drink for Pokmon Smash or Pass.
I cannot do it live right now.
I need a...
I need a drink for Pokmon Smash, or Pass.
Yes, yes.
There's no fucking way I am going to be doing that sober.
There's no- I'm not drinking now!
Who the fuck named themselves Doki Scammerbird?
I literally gave 1k!
You cannot say I'm scamming!
I gave 1k to charity!
Alright, the Pokemon...
We have Visage Chapter 1.
A Pokemon Smasher Pass.
And I'm gonna do that drunk because I cannot be so- There's no way I'm gonna be sober for this.
Oh my god, 10k!
Guys!
10 more k!
And then you get the full- Okay, I pulled 95.
95?
Do we agree on that?
Okay, I know like we said 90k.
But what about 95k?
Yo, yo, stop!
Okay, guys, just think about it, guys.
Wouldn't it be funny if it was 95k instead of 90k?
No, I said 90!
No, no, no, no.
You guys cannot gaslit me into thinking 85.
You guys cannot gaslit me thinking it was 85.
90.
90k.
Oh wait, 95 full game?
Look, the blind and deaf.
The blind and deaf says 95.
They agree.
They agree to it.
No, no, I never said 85.
I never said 85.
I said 90.
I said I was willing to go down 90.
Now I know you guys are gaslighting me.
I know for a fact that it was 90k.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I remember it was 90.
I remember, chat.
You can't gaslight me.
I'm not going to be on this.
I swear to God.
Okay.
But honestly, the amount we've accomplished today has been amazing.
Like, and the charity, the auction isn't even over.
The auction isn't even over.
We still have, like...
Guys, I'm sorry.
24 minus...
Okay, guys.
Okay, 23, 22, 21, 20, 19, 18.
We still have 18 hours left out of the auction.
And the fact that we were able to...
We were able to raise so much.
Normally, a lot of charity streams, they're like 24 hours or like multiple days.
But the fact that, like, you know, the stream itself...
Oh, no, I know.
I know.
Like, the stream itself...
Not much was really...
Like, it was mostly focused on the auction and everything.
And it was just like hanging out with you guys and just talking about the foundation and the items.
And just having like a little hangout session with all you guys.
Getting my forklift simulator on before my actual forklift certification and everything.
And the fact that we were able to...
How are you bad at math?
Because I'm fucking stupid!
I'm a streamer!
You think this brain is used on numbers?
Why do you think I fucking do dumb shit for entertainment?
That's what you know!
I have no prospects in math!
Anyway, as I was saying, back to being like fucking humble and everything.
Back to being like super humbled and generous.
As I was saying...
The stream itself, there wasn't really a lot planned for the stream itself.
I just really wanted to use it to like introduce the auction items.
I never really planned on doing a very long charity stream.
Because the full focus was on the auction itself.
It was really...
It was an amazing...
Just to see all you dragoons...
Just like...
Working together to raise so much money for such a good cause.
And being able to...
And it's still going!
Oh my god!
They're fighting over the keyboard again!
Bro!
And like, stop!
And now they're still fighting!
Trollboy is trying so fucking hard for that keyboard.
But they woke up!
A new...
A new challenger has arrived!
Cameron!
Cameron has arrived!
Cameron has woken up!
And is ready!
Alright.
For those who are new here and wondering what...
What is everyone fighting about?
Okay, don't worry.
I will put the text up for all of you guys.
For you guys to know.
Alright.
If hit 90k, I will play Visage all chapters.
Alright, here you go.
Here.
Doki's scared.
No I'm not.
Here we go.
But only...
Only if you hit that number.
Where did the text go?
Where did it go?
Where is it?
Oh here it is.
Okay.
Here.
I will only do it if...
If I hit 90k.
I will play Visage...
No!
No no no no no!
We agreed!
90k or bust!
I... guys, if I see 85k...
If I see more 85ks, I'm raising it to 90k.
95k.
Don't make me do that!
I will do it!
Guys, start playing 90k!
Or if I see more 85ks, I'm raising it up to 95k.
You can't do that Doki!
That's not...
This is my stream.
I better see 90ks in my chat!
Or I'm raising it to 95!
And that...
Is how you train your chat.
That is how...
You make sure your chat is in line.
Daniel, thank you for the five...
gift chips!
Thank you!
Okay.
Cool!
It's been... I'm really...
I think the one thing I'm like...
Super... I'm very excited...
to do a...
To do the...
cover songs with both...
Ditto and Yuusan.
I can't believe... I can't believe you guys...
knew my favorite song was...
Devshan I've Taken Thee.
Oh my god!
I...
What were the odds that you picked...
my favorite song...
for me to do a cover?
You guys just knew me so well!
I know!
You guys just knew me so...
fucking well!
It's actually crazy...
how well you knew...
like...
It is crazy how well you just...
know me guys.
I'm...
I'm like... I'm like... wow.
My true fans.
Alright.
Let me double check something...
real quick chat.
Oh my gosh.
I need to train back my...
stream stamina though.
I haven't been able to...
It's been a while since I streamed for this long in general.
So...
I've definitely been like pushing it a lot.
Because I obviously like I wanna...
be able to stream long hours...
for you guys again.
And be able to do like a lot of like...
fun things with you guys and plan...
so many fun events and everything.
But I wanna say...
also like a huge thank you to my...
team.
My management team.
Mr. Man and Little Man.
For helping me set all of this...
UP!
Oh my gosh.
It's actually crazy.
There's so much...
so much work that they all did.
So... huge shout out to them.
Zachary thank you for the 10 gifted chips!
Thank you!
I'm gonna make sure...
that... I'm gonna make sure...
that I've done everything...
on the...
stretch goals and I didn't...
put a lot on anything yet.
I'm just gonna make sure everything is good to go.
The only thing I need to do...
is I need to...
make sure that...
I post the...
community post for...
umm... what is it?
The voice packs?
And also the bento.
So other than that...
we should be good to go!
I don't think... no no no no no!
We did the hot sauce!
You can't gaslight me on that!
I remember what we did!
Daddy thank you for the 10 gifted chips!
Thank you!
I really do appreciate it!
Thank you so much!
I really do think you guys should all be...
extremely proud of yourselves.
To be able to... umm... get together.
And umm...
Just... raise...
so much money!
So much money for such a...
such a good cause.
And I'm just...
I can't believe the amount of money...
we raised.
Umm...
In general.
It's just insane.
Umm...
What about the giveaway?
Okay I'm gonna...
tweet out the giveaway right now.
Mr. Man actually gave me the tweet draft...
for a while now.
I just haven't tweeted it out!
Hahaha!
Umm... umm...
Like he's actually...
I just haven't... I just haven't done it!
Hahaha!
You know how long...
he's given it to me?
It was 2 hours ago...
by the way.
I received it 2 hours ago.
So... alright let me...
tweet this out.
I'll just do like and retweet.
You don't have to leave a...
I'll just do like... retweet.
You guys don't have to leave a like...
to enter.
Retweet...
and bark for me.
Hahaha!
Okay.
New giveaway for my debut mark as well as the upcoming...
Okay to enter, retweet...
and bark for me.
Hahaha!
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
I'm tweeting it out.
Guys!
It's free!
What do you mean?
Guys...
You can't judge me.
I can judge you guys...
because you're gonna bark in the replies.
Uh...
Follows me on Twitter.
What?
It is for charity.
Are you trying to say you guys won't bark for charity?
That's fucked up.
That's fucked up chat.
Hahaha!
Alright I'm posting it now.
Okay let me...
make sure.
I'm doing a giveaway for my debut merch... but I...
will upload this upcoming...
new merch...
Hahaha!
Okay.
Alright we're good.
Alright here we go.
Alright guys.
I would howl.
Exactly!
Derp knows it!
Derp is willing to howl for charity.
Be more like Derp.
Here you go.
See look at that!
Instant barks!
Right there!
Hahaha!
When you judge all these people that barked in the replies...
instantly...
Sell out!
Hahaha!
What do you mean?
I'm not to sell out here.
Look at yourselves in the mirror.
Look at...
Hahaha!
That's right.
Look at that.
256 barks already chat.
256 barks.
There you go.
It's just that easy.
Hahaha!
Oh my god 82,000!
Guys we're so close!
Okay guys what's...
How many more minutes to...
Okay it's like...
Okay wait let me get my calculator.
Let me get my calculator real quick.
60 minus 43.
17 more minutes.
Guys.
17 more minutes!
And you guys will get full visage!
I will change my...
I'll change my profile picture after the stream.
Don't worry I know exactly what profile picture to change guys.
You guys were very...
adamant about the fucking...
tomato bikini!
I see it!
I see the tomato bikini!
Hahaha!
Do not worry!
It's there!
It's there in the twitter replies!
Do not worry!
It's so good.
It's perfect.
Alright when can I turn it...
Okay on the 16th.
I can change it on the 16th.
Do I have anything professional to do?
No.
Okay.
We are good.
There is nothing professional to do in the next two weeks.
So I do not have anything professional to do in the next two weeks.
I do not have to worry.
Hahaha!
It's okay.
There is nothing to worry about now.
I wonder if I can actually lower...
this.
Okay.
Let's see.
It's possible to...
Oh it is!
Nice!
Alright.
Uh... we are at...
I'm gonna put this back at...
No!
Must be at least equal to your top.
Oh okay.
As long as I get rid of the...
Okay give me a sec guys.
It's time to do some little...
Alright we are gonna...
delete this.
Cause we are definitely not gonna hit 400k.
Hahaha!
There is no way we are hitting that.
That's for sure.
Alright we are gonna delete this.
And then we are gonna put this up here.
I'm just gonna fix this...
real fast guys.
And then I think we are at...
here right?
Yay!
We did it!
Alright.
Okay.
Is this all our...
milestones?
Okay.
I'm just gonna fix...
our little... I'm just gonna fix our...
our calendar real quick.
Because I can finally get rid of...
the 400k goal.
Hahaha!
Doki cheater!
There is no way...
you are gonna hit Elden Ring!
Guys there is no negotiating with that!
There is no more negotiating.
You are...
Wait what?
You are not 1.3k away.
It's 7.7.
We have agreed.
We have established that you have...
You are gonna hit 9k.
And that...
And that we have... Okay how much time...
do we have left?
46 minus 60.
There is 14...
minutes left.
Okay.
If you guys need 14...
minutes left.
Hahaha!
There we go.
So you guys will know...
how much time you guys have left...
for this.
Here.
Just to make sure.
It's that you have 14...
minutes left to hit...
90k.
I honestly don't...
think you guys... Like the thing is...
Um... I know you guys...
aren't gonna hit it.
I...
Hahaha!
Sell your...
bitcoin...
This is the...
This is the only way!
Sell your bitcoin!
Hahaha!
The doubt...
No I'm not doubting.
I know you guys...
aren't gonna fucking hit 90k.
You literally have...
13 minutes left now.
Chat.
That's true.
Yeah but this could be reverse...
psychology.
But no matter what you're gonna be doing...
what I want.
You either not hit it...
and do what I want...
or hit it...
and do what I want.
So like...
Which way do you want...
to like... spite me?
Hahaha!
You're gonna not hit it...
and prove me right.
Like prove me...
right?
Or...
hit it and prove me...
wrong.
Hahaha!
This...
This whole system is rigged.
Exactly!
Well I'm teaching you a life lesson.
No matter what you do...
this whole thing is rigged.
No matter... Oh my god!
2k?!
Who donated 2k?!
Who is it?
Timberworld!
Thank you for the 2000!
I'm doing my part!
Oh my god!
We're almost there!
We're literally...
We're literally 5k!
5k!
We're in the oil barons!
Hahaha!
It's time!
Timberworld the god!
2000!
Holy shit!
Cast!
I can't believe we're doing it.
Tempted to dump...
dump fort.
Do it!
It's for charity.
Come on!
You know you want to.
But also have enough money for food though.
So...
Please don't force yourself to donate!
Please don't force yourself!
Guys!
No matter what...
Please look after yourself.
First and foremost.
Chat!
Please look after yourself.
First and foremost.
Please.
Your pets need to eat.
You need internet to watch me.
Chat!
Your pets need to eat.
You...
You need the electricity bill.
You need the water bill.
Your family!
Your kids education!
What about your college education?
Oh my god.
2k... Oh my gosh we're so...
Wait!
Faith Smile!
Thank you for the 2k!
Holy shit!
We're 2000 left!
Guys!
2000 left!
You have 10 more minutes!
Okay.
10 minutes.
Tick tock!
I should play Jeopardy.
Wait.
Can I get copyright strike for Jeopardy?
Is there a copyright free?
Okay.
Jeopardy.
Public.
Public domain.
Domain.
Okay.
Wait.
Elevator music.
Public domain.
Free license elevator music.
Let's go.
Oh wait!
That's elevator music?
I didn't realize.
I thought that was just Schwartz music.
Okay.
Here we go guys.
We can have this while we wait.
Oh!
We hit it!
Congratulations!
We did it!
Guys!
91,000!
Oh come on.
We can hit 100k.
I believe.
No I'm joking.
We're not gonna push it.
We did it!
Everybody!
We got your visage.
Full chapters.
You should be proud of all of...
You should be so fucking proud.
Okay guys.
Alright.
You guys want another deal?
If you can do this within 8 minutes.
Guys.
Within 8 minutes.
I will defeat 2 bosses in Elder Ring.
If you hit 100k.
2 minutes.
In 8 minutes.
Can you guys do that?
Hahahaha.
In 8 minutes.
This is all for charity.
I will do it for charity.
8 minutes left.
If hit 100k.
I will play Elder Ring.
And defeat 2 bosses.
Okay.
If you guys can hit it in.
Fine.
If you guys can hit it in 5... in 8 minutes.
I'll do 5 bosses.
Okay?
Hahahaha.
You literally have 8 minutes.
You guys can do this.
I will defeat 5 bosses.
In Elder Ring.
And defeat the bosses.
What the f...
No.
We already got...
Guys.
Do not worry.
We have the dad stream.
We have all of that chat.
The auction.
The auction money.
Goes straight into...
Into the...
The stretch goals.
But I'm giving you guys extra incentives now.
I'm going to give you guys...
Extra.
So we already got Brood War.
We already got Brood War.
We already got the Dad Stream.
We already got because we're adding in the Auction money in there.
So do not worry about that.
But now if you guys can hit 100k on the Tiltify itself... on the Tiltify...
you guys will get... will get the Elden Ring Stream.
Can we... okay if you guys can do it... if you guys can do it...
I will give you five Main Story Bosses.
I'll give you guys five Main Story Bosses.
There.
We don't have time.
We don't have... well guys gotta believe in them!
Wait.
How many Main Story Bosses does Elden Ring have?
Wait a minute.
Elden Ring Main Story...
Main Story Bosses... oh fuck.
Okay.
Thank god there's a lot more than five.
One, two, three, four.
Okay.
Elden Ring every boss in order.
Let's get one, two, three, four.
Okay.
That works.
That is doable.
It's... okay.
Okay.
That is doable.
I can do it.
Oh fuck!
Guys!
I like how I was like... I was like, oh I'll do Elden Ring.
Everyone was like, go!
Go!
She's gonna do Elden Ring!
I was like, Dragons!
We weathered her down!
We did it!
We got everything we wanted, Dragons!
What?!
Not... who... who donated 4k?
4k!
Who did that?
NEXE!
Why?!
Oh my god!
NEXE fucking donated 3k!
Bro!
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Hey.
Nice.
420.
You fucking mad lads.
You waited.
You waited until I offered Elden Ring.
You guys all fucking waited until you heard Elden Ring.
You guys strike... you weathered me down.
Congratulations everybody.
You all got your Elden Ring and your visage.
But in the end, we managed to negotiate better.
Oh my god.
In the end, we all managed to raise so much money for charity.
And like honestly, that's what matters the most.
That's what matters the most.
I can't believe you guys got it in within 8 minutes.
Jesus Christ.
You guys did it within like 6 minutes too.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Uh...
You guys...
There was like 4... Sorry, not within.
There was like 4 minutes left and you guys managed to hit 100k.
Just on Tiltify alone.
In total...
If... The auction is still going on.
So currently, we've raised, including the...
Including the waiting room charity.
We raised in total around... I believe almost 200k.
And I think like that's something we should all be...
Incredibly proud of.
To be able to raise...
Um...
200k US dollars.
For...
For two charity causes.
Regarding mental health.
And both awareness and research.
Thank you everybody!
Thank you again.
It is amazing.
Um... Even like...
Even though this is only like a 6 hour stream.
We managed to raise so much money.
Within just 6 hours.
And...
The auction is still going on!
So maybe we'll be raising even more money in the end.
Uh... Within...
Uh... When the other side of the world wakes up.
For those who...
If they're still...
If they want to bid on anything as well.
So...
Um...
Thank you everybody.
It has been a huge pleasure.
I'm really happy that this was the very first event that I'm doing for all of you guys.
Um...
And...
Uh...
For a...
For such a great cause.
And...
Uh...
Yes!
The Tilify will still be open...
Will still be open until the auction ends.
So...
After the auction ends.
We will calculate everything together.
Um...
But thank you everybody!
I hope you guys...
A last shout out to all the creators.
That worked incredibly hard.
Um...
Uh...
With...
My manager.
And...
Mr. Man.
And Lil Man.
And getting all the auctions.
Auctions...
Um...
Stuff done.
As well as...
Uh...
Tilify and the foundation.
For...
Uh...
Working with us.
And giving me access to the auction house.
And...
As well as...
You dragoons!
Of course we could have done it without you dragoons!
Guys!
With a generous heart.
Um...
Uh...
Without your generosity.
And...
Your effort.
And just like...
Hanging out with me as well.
Make...
Letting me be in the stream.
This long.
For all of you guys.
You're all amazing.
And...
We all did something really special today!
Thank you everybody!
I'm gonna call it here guys.
Uh...
But thank you all.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
And if you...
Stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Mmm...
Bye!
Subtitles by the Amara.org community